all right and we are live welcome to the
iron Lords podcast episode number 53 and
it's another glorious Sunday and we are
back at the roundtable on the Lord's Day
okay various questions yes white house
who got somebody got they for volume in
the back White House meetings against
gaming yes our B stands for loot boxes
horizon zero dawn and a ton of
PlayStation News Xbox rumors and
fortnight vs. pub G to discuss so we
gonna get right into it I want to
introduce a lord who was by far one of
the most hilarious followers on Twitter
although his undeniable passion for the
PlayStation brand may rub some the wrong
way this Lord always keeps the gaming is
a multi-platform system owner and it's
never afraid to talk about subjects that
are most important to the culture hmm do
sing the member of the PlayStation
broadcast and one of the funniest online
personas in the game the lord of
trolling most responsible for getting
gamers to stay in their feelings and yet
one of the most charitable Lords in the
entire community making his debut into
the realm of the Lords my main Lord
Kratos aka JW how're you doing sir doing
good good thanks for that uh exquisite
introduction you already know everybody
it's your boy j-dub aka Kratos god of
PlayStation and all things gaming
man this here was a day in the making
today is one of the greatest days ever I
get to chop it up with all my dudes all
the Lord on this show so man let's let's
have a car show
absolutely the absolute pleasure huge
huge fan of what you do we chopped it up
a bunch of town I believe on graph as
well and I said I got to get Lord
cradles on the shadows
because over today you're ready bill and
of course we have the Four Horsemen of
gaming those usual suspects at the
roundtable please my co-host with the
Como's will be joining in progress from
that job but we still have the most
technical gaming Lord the solo gamer who
lives for the single player selfish
experience and also the Lord of the
seats its sovereign you exert good man
great to be here man and then feeling
fantastic despite the voice you know the
lord of the froggy voice today bringing
a sexy back so you know forgive my sexy
voice today back in a good capacity
whatever it is blows yeah [ __ ] long as
I'm standing right and of course we owe
the lord of combat sports it was a man
of his convictions it means nothing less
than the premium experience and is the
tiki torch extinguisher Oh beloved Lord
King how you doing sir I'm doing
fantastic shout out to the hollow I'm
gonna shout out to the multiverse oh you
some real dudes and I like you dudes
dudes know that and you dudes like me
don't let the fraud of a boss that you
got try to turn you away from the God so
when you see me you see him you know we
different we need the same thing you
know it's fortunately if I call you out
I'm coming for you I didn't call none of
you guys out that jumped up because your
boss legs was weak
well
that's a dude that did one none of this
smoke he wanna rock and hit his hands
and when I woke up like why are you
tucking that Superman's cape and I
looked at him in the eyes and I burned
his soul oh you know what he did he put
y'all up he props y'all up so I
apologize that you I had to catch any
smoke yesterday but when I'm swinging I
don't care who I'm punching alright
though I want you to understand y'all
step back up stand down y'all sit down
in the corner let your man take the heat
but he ain't gonna take me he does that
stuff watch watch Holloman very closely
well we all talked about Kings last
night what's good old combat sport daddy
fight game last night let's go man oh
man right I want to say um entre Darrell
please I'll shout out to Eagle or boxing
and shout outs Dante's boxing nation my
message you guys I know we can Thomas a
back and forth um heart rate Darrell
please retire from boxing your heart is
not in it you walking out here like
Holloman hoping that you know catch a
win and when the heat gets on you fold
like a deck of cards whatever you told
my that fight was crazy so yes yes yes
shuffle dog did the will and he put him
in his pocket we gonna we gonna um start
off with tomato can boxing first that
was on HBO now um al Heyman one messes
with Showtime and he's a promoter right
and he puts together fights he's a
matchmaker you puts together fights that
are incredible then you have the
matchmaker over at HBO who puts together
washed up tomato cans versus decent
fight is to prop them up to get you
fooled and when those decent fighters
fight anybody of substance they fold
like a deck of cards like your man
Holloman all right and so what you have
to understand is what you saw on HBO was
a profit of staged up show where the
challenges really didn't have a chance
to win
breath of versus um what was that kid
named he's just washed up kids it's made
up a second
yeah just it wasn't right alright and
Kovalev the racist um yeah he's an open
racist I mean he wears with a monkey ass
shirts and you know he disrespects black
people and stuff like that he had a
black train and he disrespected him in a
manner I don't tuck call anybody races
when I was saying it doesn't to be you
know true but you know he has tendencies
and this is up breaking bringing this
fine he got humbled by the god on jury
award um but he won yesterday and those
cars had no substance it was no spark
nobody really cared but when you took
yourself over to Showtime and you had
Deonte the bronze bomber Wilder the
champion the WBC champion the USA
champion versus Lewis King Kong Ortiz
listen I said Lewis King Kong Ortiz
so you know if you're talking about you
got a us Yoshio your nickname is King
Kong you bring his fire to the pot you
had a fight with either man could win it
was a pick'em and it ball down to
substance who you were inside because
you were nice we got fight not tested
right that's it
okay so when I tell you boxing is 90%
mental and then 10% physical all you
have to do is train for that 10 percent
but while you're training your body that
had 10% your training your mind that 90
percent and when you have visualizing
you're speaking in and you're putting it
into existence yesterday Deontay Wilder
was in the midst of fighting King Kong
north and I gotta say King Kong who
can't call came to smash he caught the
other one the core Louis Ortiz first
with a straight right hand and a left
hook that had put him to the ropes and
put him down and you said haha it's all
now Blago King Luis Ortiz got up and
proceeded to put mixed upon Deontay
Wilder
and when I'm telling you he put mix upon
this man he put mix on this man that
those shots that he was getting hit with
what it dropped any heavy weight no
Chris man conviction and who he is and
what he knows
would not allow his knees to touch that
campus mm-hmm
okay so he bit that bottom lip down he
got me I told my daughter cuz my
daughter was watching with me I told my
daughter I said look at his eyes baby
she said what daddy I said his eyes
never wavered I said his eyes was alert
the whole time he was watching Luis
Ortiz as Luis Ortiz was trying to tee
off on him and every time Luis Ortiz hit
him he said to himself I got you now
it was shades of Evander Holyfield
rittick bow around classic me I remember
that I was right classic yeah boy
Deontay Wilder and I told my daughter I
said baby I said Luis Ortiz just gave
you the old man shuffle she said what's
that I said look at his shoulders when a
boxer jerks his shoulders up and down
because he's taking a second thought in
his head he's breathing he can't believe
what's going on there I said that man is
finished and he's a beaten man now watch
yes Deonte Stanton was so strong when he
started to connect on Luis Ortiz his
knees touch their canvas he went down he
was a broken man because he hoped to win
that fight mm-hmm he can win that fight
Deontay Wilder loom he would win that
night got you so it's all about that
mental game like conviction you know I'm
saying and when you get tested in that
deep water who is going to the ground
that man
I'll tell you that I'm not the biggest
Deontay Wilder fan because you know I
like the technical fighters and E's it's
kind of disgust but I have to appreciate
the fact that like in the heavyweight
division one punch could change the
course of everything and then to like
the man's heart demands determination
like his fight IQ is not the best but as
I King said like his ability to just be
like no matter what I'm winning any mean
it may look disgusting but like I got a
garden like the man's heart the man's
heart is unparalleled mm-hmm no shots
would have dropped anybody and God so
what's going on in the UFC last night's
arm so you have seen last night I missed
most of it I guess I was telling you
guys before we got on I went to see
Black Panther again with my knees that
was slash a date night as well so I
missed a lot of it but I was able to
catch the loot the last two fights on
the penalty card which is a Frankie
Edgar Bryan otega and K and cognos
dislike we're painted fans big Frankie I
get fans hurt women hurt the kid the kid
is gonna go down as one of the best to
ever do one of the most technical
technically sound fighters we've seen in
this entire generation man willing to
fight anybody and most of the time guys
that are bigger than have been stronger
than him and he went in there I guess
against a young guy Brian Ortega who is
considerably longer than him this is a
guy that kind of in length reminds me of
John Jones where he can use his elbows
like their jabs and there's one thing
about Frankie that's a kind of deficient
in him is the fact that he doesn't know
when to run away he got that bone yeah
he'll go toe to toe when he should just
kind of grapple it and and you know hold
on and and that's what happened like
Ortega caught him with a left elbow that
looked like like a straight punch she
just caught him and then he managed to
kind of get Frankie and kind of like a
moon tiger rip and he kept them close
and he finally was able to rattle off an
uppercut that sent Frankie down and that
was that like that was that the first
time in his career that rosenheim ever
Frankie's been finished Frankie's never
never been finished yeah Wow so that was
it was like changing of the guard right
so how you feel like I felt was like a
little it was good or take or take as a
special talent and Frankie again that's
not to say Frankie can't come back next
time and whip on somebody because he
still has it but I think his ability to
fight guys that are bigger than him
stronger than him to have physical
attributes that kind of put him at a at
a disadvantage I don't think he has it
you know he's just getting older you
know I mean he's he's a young guy who's
kind of an old fighter completely um and
then we have the main event we had a
cyborg Chris cyborg versus
Cooney styie coolest guy is a Jackson
one codon fighter so you know this did
she come in at the last minute it was
just a mandatory I think it was a
mandatory you know okay they were
talking about it for a minute but it's
like yeah i'ma let you continue yeah I
mean she's a young fighter um coming in
at the very least she had the the kind
of the the 20/20 vision of Holly Holmes
fight kind of to see where where Holly
went wrong and fighting cyborg um and
you know Jackson we've done these guys
are like penises in the ring when it
comes to like strategy and tactics ox oh
yeah definitely that camp so her going
in she was a considerable underdog
mm-hmm to be honest she wasn't ready for
sidewalks power at all she didn't seem
like she had any sort of head movement
or anything like that and she got caught
with a lot of cyborgs punches but at the
same time the Mike at the same time she
was game to try to take her down and it
seemed like at least physically like in
terms of power she could almost kind of
in terms of grappling and like hold you
cyborg up against
the the the octagon it seemed like she
was willing and able to sort of do that
for a little bit but soon the sideboard
created distance she let those hands go
and it was a wrap like she was
completely overmatched and it was over
before the end of the after was e versus
the fight and of course it is law
kognito here we're gonna spread that
gaming realness on the ILP not telling
you what you want to hear but what you
need to hear so before we get into what
the Lords are playing this week I want
to start off with Lord
Kratos his video game system history his
passion for the God of War series and of
course what led him to joining that
amazing PlayStation broadcast so Lord
Kratos let's start from the beginning
let's get some og status talk going on
well it's like the first video game
system the Atari 2600
I still have every system I've ever
owned I still have it to this day I'm
trying to build this little Museum that
sounds great bro my materials everything
from Atari 2600 The Odyssey I keep in
mind I got my gaming stuff from up from
my older brother and you know he was
much older than me so it was just by
chance you know I had everything so yeah
man a big gaming you know since the
early 80s
since out you know since there was one
button on the controller so yeah so that
that's that's what it is man from you
know Atari 2600 it's for the NES two
turbo graphics 16 Neo Geo all at the 3do
I mean just all the way to the Dreamcast
now I'll tell you guys this man if if
there's one system that I think I shed a
tear when they finally closing doors man
was Sega when with the Dreamcast that
system was ahead of his time and we have
to you know give that system to shout
out because it did any and everything
first from bringing us the high visual
fidelity graphics I mean the whole
online play yes
you know broadband just just everything
ahead of his time was just it's too bad
that they didn't work out but it kind of
paved the way for you know the you know
for all the stuff to follow but yeah so
that's my game in history man you know
obviously I'm on the you know majority
of time I'm on the PlayStation because
that's where the bulk of games are you
know have the X I have you know the
switch in a game on PC too so question
your PlayStation 2 did you ever do you
have a campout story did I do camp out
for that Playstations are doing let me
tell you so I'm in college right at this
time
in college just disjoint about to drop
at $2.99 back in the day now if you in
college trying to say this 99
you didn't eat to this day the original
system my kids you see that system over
there and the work exactly camped out at
Best Buy
overnight we showed up like freaking you
know 3:30 in the afternoon and all the
way to overnight so they go indoors at
10 o'clock yeah it was a gave us a
ticket to standing to stand in line or
whatever and some people just came then
they just left they said oh yeah we'll
come back later man them dude's did not
get him so yeah that was the pinnacle
right there of me standing outside in
line you know just fellowshipping with
gamers and now we got social media and
YouTube and stuff like that we can do
that online but mmm yeah PST pave the
way to for where we are now
absolutely I give that question because
of when you talk about the PlayStation
and then like how you know everybody was
camping out how hard it was to get with
such a hot item at the time like I also
think it back that what you said that
usually how expensive was we had to say
but didn't your history you got me you
always do it's real safe I did say
because my older brother right okay so
at this time he has a job he's working
so he's able to do that so it was just
just by chance that I grew up like that
until I got older and got my own stuff
oh god I was like yo no cartridges with
the system like sounds $200 per game per
quarter voltages were it's like big as a
Oxford Dictionary keep in mind keep in
mind oh this was the same home unit that
everything it was fax fax yeah cuz I was
gonna I was gonna say which is that it
kind of what Neal G was kind of the
first true
arkaid yes sister what you played in
arcade was exactly the size you played
at home and a lot of people don't know
there was a memory card where you could
save it at home and go to the arcade
which quarter's popped me in and have
all your saves and everything with your
friends 75 bucks
exactly so we have to you know we have
to give you know these older consoles we
have to give them props because they
paved the way it's not like we just woke
up one day and the Xbox 360 was there
with the hard drive and the Wi-Fi card
and things you know a lot of you guys I
don't know you know I almost you guys
are but you remember the first online
gaming was with the Sega Genesis with
the state of cop in that car
yes so who you let you screw you look
about three minutes because I taking me
back cuz was it um I think it was
collects band 33 six modems you killed
aya we will get that crinkling sound man
you but you be in a game Indian somebody
call any disconnection you blame me yeah
why did grandma call that was gaming at
its finest I respect that one last
question about about the system's we we
are all GZ so it's good to actually talk
to someone that understands our language
therefore as far as done you said turbo
graphics 16 which I was very go all out
did you have like the bass did you do
Turbo Express or did you do the CD or
you get none on the side I did the base
I didn't have the CD and that was very
short-lived so I'm glad I didn't
that but my prized collection and every
every now and then I'll post some of my
prized possessions and stuff is an
official turbo graphics 16 Street
Fighter 2 brand-new in the sleeve it's
like the most because most people
remember Street Fighter 2 from the SNES
Super Nintendo
no it was before that most people don't
realize that the turbo graphics 16 man
it had you know better color better
graphics everything on it was it was
higher in but it cost so much at the
time it was another expensive console
where the NES you know in the Super NES
and stuff like that they were in are
they would be like what the PlayStation
in the Xbox is today they will be on
those comfort levels also you're always
gonna have that system that's out there
like eight hundred dollars no you take
every back makers I remember that sister
to and they everything has to shout the
law King man if it wasn't for him
balling us broke people the King and and
the Wiz get a chance to play the turbo
Express a lot of people don't understand
I played gaming on the go but I never
owned it now keep in mind this thing at
its time was better than the Sega Game
Gear yes as far as fidelity the graphics
and being able to take your cartridge
from the turbo graphics pop that puppy
in here and nomad you mean the Nomad not
the game gear you mean no matter
cartridge on the gold
there was a nomad yes that came way late
and no Mac you like yeah you right right
right so I guess I guess you're right in
that in that instance because with the
game you had to get specialized games
for the game gear you couldn't take like
you yes I came lady are you right on
that so raised on that but yeah you can
pop your game in here
go walk out there now you know those
double-a batteries on the four batteries
like that you can only get them off
off-brand batteries you know back before
I forget cuz even with your turbo story
that was the first perfect something
that brought something back for me and
for his arm Atari Lynx moving all around
and stuff like this I'm trying to
acquire all myself bats I got my Neo Geo
and stuff like that but how did you hold
I did not keep in mind like this so my
gamer remember I told you in the
beginning just all about my brother and
my big brother
throughout the years man I had these
plastic bands and I would always play my
stuff and when I'm done take it put it
into being silly duh I'm good to go so
these things just kind of been in the
closet for so many years and I'll pull
them out every so often even now I'll
pull them out once a you know every
every now damn plug them up and have the
kids take a look and kind of get to know
where game we come from because right
now they're kind of spoiled on the
switch and the PlayStation and Xbox and
stuff like that they don't realize the
origin
we get that so my little son you know
he's eight years old I like when I'm
gonna hit a hook Atari in the house
playing he was like what is that this is
the og game this is what we did he was
like but it only has one button like he
doesn't understand that color bright so
he's looking at me and like the system
economics was like Menem graphics and I
did it like looking at explain it might
give you a headache like two bit it
gives you that history and it kind of
solidifies what's your experience like
all you got to do is pull out one of
those systems and it brings back years
and years of oh my god where you were
what you did what you were doing exactly
where he was where point in your life
you nailed it it's a sentimental value
to that because this is your childhood
just all this stuff is wrapped up your
childhood is wrapped up in that you
should absolutely no doubt the lineage
which is definitely certified lo creo
certified out here these gaming streets
so as far as now we know you are Lord
Kratos so let's start with that passion
for the God of War franchise
taking on well ok so I'm gonna tell you
guys this right I've always liked that
award that's just kind of been my thing
but I've never I'm gonna tell you the
moment the date and the time that I took
on that persona 83 2016 the orchestra's
plan they're planning something some
tune hit my ear and I was like this
sounds familiar
Green is black Dean you slowly hear you
hear the Atreus walk up and he's talking
and then Kratos came out of the shadows
and you can see piece of his beard it
was over it was a rap that just
solidified facts out a war to me and
that's when I became Kratos that that
whole thing how they set it up and how
they play house was the defy this
edition of why I love this franchise you
know what did it for me look at us
whose boy came out of there and it was
it was like they did they did it man and
in that sea I still go back from time to
time and watch that particularly III
because that eats me kind of kind of
started the whole trend in being they
finished it off with a fire fire PF sex
you know I'm gonna tell you guys is yes
I'm a playstation century guy and now
you know hey I'm Kratos I can't you know
you know ain't running from it but but
at the end of the day that did it for me
the same way
mister wine mr. wine let's rewind back
on the 360 when they first shown the
Xbox 360 they showed uh God Gears of War
II creature up there that's something we
never ever seen before in gaming so that
there solidified me on the Xbox 360s so
there's particular moments in gaming
that will solidify you off or something
and that's just kind of how gaming is
and high goals ax man you take
absolutely that those are classic
moments you remember what it was where
you was I felt when you saw it yes that
is beautiful that he understood that at
that point right there when he saw that
he said this is the exact format this
persona resonated with me so don't wait
for a second but God I hear what you say
about like those are like amazing
amazing moments you never never forget I
know for me personally like like our war
wasn't it really grow I came up to the
series late I think actually um correct
me if I'm wrong so I've didn't Vida do
like a compilation or has some of the
older ones or they have a second one I
think well the PSP had two portable ones
and I think they were they had they
remastered them for
yes for I think they're playable on Vita
I believe they are um yeah so I think
that and I think Vita didn't have its
own specific version as well I didn't
have like a spin-off like uh no no no na
Vida they didn't buy that time someone
he wasn't investing any real first party
stuff in the video like like okay so I'm
sorry I meant to say P it was a PSP then
maybe I'm confused that's what it was
now the PSP PSP had the compilation or
did they have a separate to spin off one
or for PSP they had two separate ones
for PSP that were then remastered and
put onto PS 3/4 I believe so the God of
War 3 was the remap so that they brought
to ps4 for RAGBRAI and then you had the
chain of olympus in the Ghost of Sparta
that was on the PSP now I was I was kind
of set because they never made one for
the Vita
so that's novita that's a whole
different story
I sleep right next to it so it's right
next to me and every once in a while
I'll pop it in and you know play some
stuff on it what was funny was that PSP
go I got roped into that craft complete
digital I mean it's great when you when
you jailbreak you this fan once once
sony said we're taking it offline I said
man that's when I firstly first realized
that a company really don't care about
you like a lot of times people play
Madden and they play Madden years after
that game is gone they Dylan to other
Madden's and ea keep those servers open
and then they tell them after a couple
of their years yo bro you know please
upgrade yeah
we're gonna shut down the service at a
certain date so he didn't do that
Sony what Sully did was um they just
shut it out they just shut it you went
to log on and there was nothing so if it
wasn't jailbroken you weren't able to
have access to anything or content that
you have purchased with that gold now of
course through the PlayStation Network
you still had content there but those
games that was specific to that PSP go
no it was not a go guys this what how
long after the end of life was system
should they continue to support it
before before you I want to save that's
a great question I want to say that cuz
we gonna get into that with the topic
later far as PlayStation definitely say
that question we bring it back though
cuz that's a great question Lock rattles
oh one last thing we do in reference to
your history and everything now one I
know you've created that persona and
then I've noticed at you all my boy the
PlayStation broadcast how did how did
that started you get it linked up with
those dudes you know what uh one one day
brought hit me up or whatever in you
know we were just kind of talking in the
DM z-- and stuff like that and and I
kinda you always kind of you know
obviously he's a PlayStation centric guy
and he'd always post up so I would
always like and read Sweden stuff like
that so we just kind of got together in
the d-ends and you know ended up on his
show and then I did an interview of him
on my channel so that's just kind of how
we worked out and you know I'm if you
noticed I really don't push my own
channel or anything because I just
really don't have time like that you
know if I can show up I will and if not
in I can't so I'm a firm believer if I
can't dedicate myself 100% to something
then I'm not gonna do that because I
don't want to just put out you know
crappy content or Sun here and then not
there so you know I'm just featured on a
lot of people's and stuff like that so
we just you know just been chopping it
up every since man well yeah I checked
you out over there I was like down with
the girl like the boys hilarious man
real full shadow so hard right now for
you
is hollow where we'll see yesterday when
he is popping you took this Superman
cape you got stomping your chest down
mustard seed heart rule men recognize
real we understand we talk our
vernacular resonates with each other
when you talk about everything that he
said about his game in history and games
in between all these people in over your
head this tough one will put you on the
spot all right
top five creaming franchises of all time
I already know what one of them should
top five gaming franchises okay you
already know God of War solidified The
Last of Us
yeah that their man is yeah The Last of
Us I don't even have to say anymore it's
already halo I got mean that's that's
what that is right like that's legendary
that that's that put the whole thing on
the map so you gotta give shout out to
that
let's see gran turismo most people know
I'm a racing that right so I'm into for
the cars and everything so I'm gonna
give that's just that solidified that
and uh it's gonna be in a generation man
that touched you geez alright so I'm
gonna go ahead and go with the 2k series
mmm
are we gonna pass it's just the 2k
series however okay I mean you got both
right the the NBA 2k the first suit k
was the first thing that kind of put it
on the map with the free style controls
and stuff that we can do the graphics
stuff like that Indian NFL 2k also put
it cool I mean Sega I mean it was just
it was just as you're solidified in
history we all know right now we're
begging for you know either EA to go out
of business or for the NFL license to go
away so we can have the definitive
football game that we know can be
created we know you take 2k baseball to
the side they try they try absolutely
fantastic franchises you name so we
gonna get now into what the Lords are
playing specifically this week now
warlord cradles are guess when you touch
in the dr what else what else have you
been touching this week as far as our
games okay I've been on that switch yeah
then maybe dropping some games man left
and right all all I mean you know at
least three times a week they're
dropping some games so I picked up the
payday 2 got fed obviously I got you
know the bayonetta in the physical of
that so I in so do I have over 150 games
right now
I got a 400 gig memory card
so yeah go extra like when I go in i go
in nineteen terabytes for my xbox that's
cool this we play that's what's up now
lord solve what's been going on this
week what you've been ratted I finally
finished Assassin's Creed origins
offense the story there yeah I mean I
love Assassin's Creed man but it is
something about them like they're parts
of that story where the exposition is
great like their moments went when byuk
assassinate somebody that he really goes
deep into them because you know they
after when you assassinate a big person
in SAS his Creed is always I can cut
seen you know in they explain why they
were doing what they were doing you know
the Templars whatnot
and it's not most things are really
great but then like it seems like once
they get to the end of the story they
try to rush everything and everything
feels rushed like the resolutions feel
rushed to light so hey I was a little
disappointed at the end but overall man
it's it's a great tacit Creed game man I
don't want one this year don't give me
another one all you want to break yeah
please give me yeah um let me see on the
switch I've been inching forward and SLS
as always and playing Bayonetta 1 and I
put two to the side to that so I
finished one again um and it's funny
back on now on the Xbox one
um so I played all the back compact
games that came out the ones with the X
enhancements that this just came out man
like they they doing great work with
those games man like for the forth of
horizon looks like it could have been a
launch title for the Xbox one like
that's not a thank you like digital um
found you just get something on it and
they were like it is so spectacular on
the X in 4k I'm like talking about for
someone what Xbox
pressive one the least impressive one is
is this fable and fable still looks
fantastic
didn't really fix but um crackdown looks
amazing man but I tell you this about
crackdown like going back to it I start
over from the beginning
like I can really see that the game is
still fun right it hasn't necessarily
aged the greatest it's still fun but I
you know when I initially said that's
all I want from crackdown 3 I realized
that's a lie
like I really not even graphically liked
the game gameplay when we saw it and
played it at e3 like we saw it hasn't
evolved in terms of gameplay and you
know blowing stuff up is cool but like
even in terms of the animations they
could do so much more with the powers
we're like the world they just they
haven't done they hadn't done anything
at that point so I really hope this
going back to the drawing board gives us
something different because I don't want
more crack down one I realize that now
okay it's funny I said that because I
never still really got busy with crack
that when I think when it came out it
was like a promotion if you like
reserved or pre-order to something Halo
did you get it wasn't it I think I do
want to just play it just to kind of get
me because again I'm not really crack
down guys when some Xbox guy like I
don't really get a chance to play so
it's interesting you say that so I just
want to see what the core foundation was
really all about that had everybody kind
of hype about it you know yeah I mean
it's just what like wanton destruction
fun destruction like but I said I think
I said this before uh you know on the
show back in the day like there was
something that they initially said about
crackdown that never really came into
play with the game which was like um
they you can approach the game any which
way they had a lot of the bosses were
situated at the top of these skyscrapers
right and you have to go to like this
gauntlet to get to them but if you had
the proper powers um at that point like
you could do crazy stuff like stack cars
one on top of the other and make your
way up the side of the building and just
listen to the boss you can do like the
the
world was destructive when such a way
where you can have like agency and how
you approach things and that never made
it into the game so something like that
would make crackdown 3 a lot more
appealing so I really think you mean to
tell us we're gonna get what they
promised from the first crackdown no I
don't even know we're getting that I'm
sorry and real quick the last thing the
last thing that I played that I'm
reinstalling the cradles here um I want
to talk about this real quick I real
slow rise man
like right let's talk about I had him
played rise in a minute I said let me
see how it runs on the X I know they
don't did no enhancement but yo seeing
seeing the new god of war and seeing how
they grounded him more and how they
don't like the behind the back like
perspective and how it's just it's not
as floaty as older god of war games and
looking and looking at rise in the
gameplay of rise to meet God of War is
what I would have wanted rise to to be
like digging it feels like it let you go
back into rise first of all rise is
still a beautiful game like you all
gorgeous game remember they did that on
old G Xbox one we're connected tats
without the 50% without the steam shout
out the Crytek that game for its time as
a launcher people can clown it on the
CTE s and I can understand that but from
a visual perspective you cannot deny
rise you know amazing look you can't I
mean if you look at it like I felt that
the launch of Xbox one was in terms of
games was better than ps4 like I rise in
rising three to run yeah I um so yeah
like playing that honestly like the game
again like the QTE stuff with the
color-coded stuff like it creates a flow
to the gameplay that's cool but it also
creates a repetition that gets you know
kind of boring after a while because you
kind of seen all the animations and
whatnot what-o like to me god of war is
what I would have wanted from a second
rise and Max goes please please give us
another Rock
my eyes that game was designed to be a
Kinect game as many they switched it out
the point I'm glad they did they would
have more time to tailor-make this game
or if it wouldn't been built with the
Kinect in mind think about how badass
that game would can we all just put a
thought process and how bad the Kinect
brand ruined the Xbox it was so
successful on the 360 yeah yeah we would
be saying why didn't you continue on
with that success on the next one you
should I'm saying yeah so it's one thing
with having something successful and you
know wanting to imply that into your
next-gen it's another thing to be like
you got no it you got no no choice you
accepting this connected you know see
laurels 2.2 on a standpoint listen much
as we couldn't stand it man you know
they were forcing a stupid TV narrative
the thing about it was if you look at
how successful it was on 360 and it was
a peripheral right right the way they're
looking at it from a business standpoint
is like look we can't segment the base
everybody has to happen to encourage
more development for so I understood the
process but it just again it just was
still forced and it was yeah if the
Gators did not want it we said it at
launch like if they were gonna force it
finish up solving I got him on a truck
yeah we're gonna have to eat a hundred
dollars if they wanted to really push
and we ate it exactly 400 do you think
the narrative would have been different
if it was the same process the ps4 with
the Kinect it would have gone to the
power thing because again once it came
out that it was that it was slower
because resource on connector power was
something but I feel like the biggest
point the mother had was the money
let's say $100 more I don't care what it
is you saying okay both these new things
came out that's what you did to new
things
what is $100 more really pretty much the
same amount of games price because in my
personal opinion no way I could say this
without having any kind of a backlash
but Kratos is here but anyway my
personal anguish like the Xbox one on
launch had better games it didn't matter
what they had in game wise because let's
be real here you know they had the same
third parties and Xbox slightly better
first party the price came down to it
okay what it is hundred dollars hundred
I'm sorry miss a bit nickels right now
is the most powerful console in the
world yeah it costs $500 and I know it's
selling right we know it's selling but
I've already I've always said that $500
price tag will always be the anchor that
keeps it from going more from being in
milk because right now you got to switch
at $2.99 you can pick up a PlayStation
slim in an Xbox one s4 you know under
200 bucks yeah [ __ ] 85 yeah I mean on
top of that right you can spin $200 of a
slim you spend $200 on a VR for $400
that's still cheaper then we have the X
max you know you have all these
exclusives and everything else so you
people you know the hardcore gamers
we're always we're gonna buy everything
anyway it doesn't matter how much it
cost
but casuals the majority of the people
will not and we just have to get that in
our head I honestly think if it would
have been $400 in the Master Chief
collection came out with the Xbox one
mm-hmm and backwards-compatible was on
launch I think we'd be as a different
story yeah it's nice that you know you
know
backwards-compatible the ability came
out but let's be real here by the time
it came out to Daniel let me get you
that there in Sheol or edit my co-host
with almost my brother from another
mother the difficult game Conqueror and
the house of the young wolf my man Lord
addict are you doing back off work
I like that difficult game I'm not gonna
lie the tumor eating how many tied a
little couple times like well I hate
game like I like games like blood-borne
Dark Souls because the game's difficult
but it's designed to be difficult they
don't up the difficulty by making the
game unfair okay so he's gay like having
like dude like how and my nosh I'm
shooting you with an aka to the head and
I just knock off your mask like that
makes no sense like to the point where I
was had better consistency using a bowl
mmm thanks well they want you to use
their boat okay I'm gonna say this I'm
probably gonna get a lot of flack for
this next there you go
like what I've seen on uncharted it
really seems like unchartered is the
easier of the two are hard well I'm
waiting yet but there's one big big
difference I've seen UK you can't hit
firing cover mmm writer you literally
had to come out of cover to shoot is so
frustrating because all these people
were one shotting me yeah yeah like I
have to literally shoot one it got to
the point where I'm like I have a better
chance at may laying some of these
people I literally come out of cover
start hitting them with a knife knock
one down start hitting the other dude
and hope to god none of them shoot me I
give you a lot of credit I mean I'll
watch this couple your streams man and
I'm like I'm too old
I'm sorry shut up the Lewis software he
would talk about what is this the last
last week I'm like I saw that difficulty
thing gloss off what did you talk about
besides to be sick I got so many games
I'm putting it on casual just to get to
the end too much good stuff out here to
be trihard me too hard on is this pub
Jean is important the smoke is real
monkey monkeys punch voltage deaf singer
deaf that's my do right day for real rap
will you let baby we in the streets we
like I said we got that rotation poppin
maybe 10 people in the chat my guys
let's rotate if somebody lags out switch
chicken as they taste great when when
xbox went down this week that was on my
switch Mario yo - Mario they got
balloons now we got a free download you
know what's a good word I can make fun a
hanker moment is that we don't know it
this dis duel goes on his podcast and
was being ambiguous with some weird
challenge then he comes at me talking
about oh now you ready for you
specifically King at except we we've
been ducking in
anchorman will have to get you to back
up I got to see something that you've
done anything remotely hard where's the
scuppers don't mean everyone is you're
destroying your fan base because now
your friends are looking over at you
like I'm just looking over and they see
the more you talk the more you let
people just really be quiet sit down in
the corner and watch real men to real
men you to siege and you ducked business
then you claimed that she was on a date
oh oh I said I'm on a date on December
the 11th of last year but anyway so
forth but I wasn't playing on definitely
or actually put Kingdom Come delivered
for a little bit and the extra ex-con
200k up there I'm a huge as come Fame
and War of the chosen DLC completely
changes the game it's brand new so much
new mechanics oh so much fun been
enjoying that and force which it's been
I'm actually wool the blade I'm close to
the last level of her
a man's getting the difficulties picking
up I'm really really enjoying this I'm
gonna knock that out get another one
down I'm gonna switch back law hopefully
by next week that should be done we will
get into this aw poor works folks cuz we
got a hold on let me just interrupt you
like did you have this like Snape
somewhere cuz know you knew multiverse
episode 79 this has been saved this
rainy day we can do this now that
everyone's in agreement everyone here's
what's being said cuz no one heard that
but um we can do whatever y'all want to
do you know say in a multiverse it's
cool whatever when we beat you
well first off I want to know who's on
your team because it's all attempts to
move I think Sam I think our editor has
jump ship we have to go by this date if
he wants to use this date so much who
was on that episode because that's all
you can use okay anyway so last week's
photos oh right I've spoken with the
recent results of a possible
relationship between Microsoft and Sega
of Japan what do you think is the best
course of action for Xbox the winner at
52% in a fairly competitive three-way
ILP poll was the Microsoft shipped by
Sega entirely group 41% was Microsoft
should only partner with Sega for select
IPs and coming in for shallow third
place at 7% was I don't care unless
Shenmue 3 is covered group think about
this Kratos what do you think about this
as well these are Sega
supposing Microsoft rule is which one
did you prefer
well obviously number two right that's
the most realistic one but most people
don't realize that American company
cannot buy a Japanese company like that
the Sega would never sell to Microsoft
that's so we can kick number one out the
door but number II they all my Sammy I
believe is
like Sammy won't say go something like
that yeah so so keep keep in mind right
it makes sense you don't want all the
IPAs you just want the ones that's gonna
make you the most money in the ones that
people are asking for so you know I say
cut a five-game deal with them select
those IPS and try to work out a deal and
get it and close the deal on I really
unfortunately I think Microsoft is
already working on they're focusing all
their attention on the next-gen and not
this one here so I think even if they do
too with those IPS it's gonna be two to
three years before they they come to
fruition anyway right now they can cut
the deals to get the games that Sega or
gonna have coming out in the meantime
just to get them on the Xbox platform
because we've seen games like you know
the the Kwame and and all these other
you know Capcom and in Sega games all
these games are just by a default are
coming on Sega on Sony's platform and
not necessarily on the Xbox I don't
understand why but obviously there
there's a deal that Sony's cutting
whether they couldn't have checks or you
know whatever it's not on the Xbox and I
think that's that's a shame absolutely
yeah I mean it's interesting to see like
I said we'll see what actually comes
with me room was if anything I thought
it was interesting
fanboys was out dating these streets you
know we get a rumor flag going until we
had a lot of show we got to get into
these topics we was nicely distracted by
the multiverse which are sovereign
politics going on in the game man what's
going on out here in these gaming
streets all right so what do you guys
want me to talk about first a yes or a B
stuff or the Trump gate let's go let's
go
first we need to talk more about this
anchor right they are just waving
was good with the with the white house
well okay so in response to the florida
school shootings right um there's been
talk about where there's been a lot of
finger-pointing right and obviously at
some point the finger was gonna get
pointed at gaming once again that's
happened years ago and it's it tends to
happen when things like this go down
so um I guess last week President Trump
threw his White House press secretary
Sarah Huckabee made a statement
indicating that he was meeting this
coming week with members of the gaming
industry like CEOs and whatnot to
discuss what can be done to sort of
address these issues that they see in
gaming um and the funny thing about it
is that the ESA or no one else
associated with the esa no no company
and gamer you know innocent game was
aware of this uh of this summit that's
going on next week apparently so right
so so clearly they didn't receive this
news the guy's a liar they didn't
receive the memo on this right and I
guess and what King says is true like
it's one of those things where this is
where I stand on it right the fact the
fact that it's getting federal talk time
it's something that we need to think
about for a second right okay I
mentioned this last week um and talked
about like Phil Spencer and his speech
about how an awful seat right how
changing now changing the culture of
gaming is something that it has to be
done but at the same time I felt like it
was a call to arms to sort of look Mike
whatever else is going on wrong with
gaming we need to fix it we need to
address it ourselves before somebody
from the outside decides they want to
address it so yeah you know you know
saying no no commentary on Donald Trump
at his politics but to me in speaking
only about his disposition and and the
type of person he appears to be he is
someone who will not take lightly to be
to being ignored in this in this thing
so if he's just you know just shooting
from the lip and none of this comes and
nothing comes up
this fine you know gaming should just
forget about that he ever mention it
keep moving forward if he does move
forward with something official where he
does actually want to meet with people I
think it's in gaming's best interests to
address it um living there you think the
thing about it is again they don't have
there's no real argument there like when
they bring it to the table they're not
gonna have a substantial argument just
gonna say oh look what happened here it
has to be because of these influences
it's the same argument that's been
that's been going on for years and
nobody has any proof the reason why this
stuff is like super fake news is because
the last time I picked up Call of Duty
didn't cover the air ar-15 the fact that
it doesn't come with a gun
I don't care unless you your video game
comes with a lethal weapon for you to go
outside and cause mass destruction and
this is fake news so I mean um you say
millions of kids play Call of Duty how
many millions of kids is all her killing
nobody
so you're talking about the kid that's
in in some place I'm not even gonna pick
a place that's racist because I'm stupid
because there's pocket kids all over the
world these kids other outside
influences that's pushing them to this
Avenue to do these atrocities and we're
not gonna use video games as the
scapegoat for that conversation that
conversation shouldn't even be talked
about that clown is over there talking
mess nobody knows what he's talking
about he's another hollow man but he's a
hollow man at physical I'm not giving
credence to this of a hollow man look
okay let's all but now one get look
later I mean that's the truth like again
it's a scapegoat being skateboarded as
we were you know on multiple occasions
in the past humans over here first part
of what's often reference to the
president the White House and they're
trying to get involved with gaming well
so right now right there's just just big
talking right now the nra is being
bombarded because people pointing
fingers at them calling them a terrorist
group in yeah yeah yeah
a lot on this stuff here's the thing
about gaming right there are more people
who game outside of the United States
than it is in America so but America's
only seem to be the only place with this
problem so what is it about America that
the outside world outside of our borders
don't have this problem and you just
look at it at one thing and it's the
guns so people don't want to talk about
that right they don't want to talk about
the guns it's their memory right yada
yada we don't want to alter it mmm and
so it's like well we got to do something
cuz right now kids are screaming parents
are screaming we got to do something so
the easiest thing we can do is blame it
on video game and try to pass a
legislation that you know has something
to do with video games ending weekends
you know ourselves on the back and say
okay we've we've just stopped cleaning
of guys from going out with a ar-15s and
killing up everybody you know the
problems done that's just this is all it
is it's nothing
it's smoke and mirrors daddy feels like
stationed off of wood really matters and
put it on some is this blame displays
actors redirection just complete
redirection of where and so you're not
looking at the actual problem completely
understand you guys coming from I mean
again you know when I got the news loss
are brought to topic up you know I've
seen a little disgusted gaming is very
near and dear to me obviously and a
shout out to Lord rap and cradles we
were actually on a brat rant and we
actually had this discussion I believe
in reference to when we got the news
initially that they were looking into
gaming and ultimately at the end of the
day you know gaming has its place you
know obviously you know I am biased this
is my platform we talk you know our
platform we talk on gaming but at the
same time we can't lose sight of what
the real issues are you know and and and
we know what's going on Charlotte King
as far as you know the weapon aspect you
know the points that Laurel Kratos made
you know just one of those things that
okay yeah you can look at it you know I
know we have an ERP system with ratings
things can be improved I get that I'm
not saying gaming is above being looked
at I'm not even gonna go this it has
absolutely no influence but at the same
time talk King said what's actually
going on here is what we kind of need to
focus and I just thought it was quite
humorous that um
the ESA said they didn't get
Oh about you know our president wanting
to to meet with that you know meet with
that relative but I did hear getting
update I did hear that um that they
apparently these memos will be going out
the advice will be going out next week
that's what we'll see what happens to
that and you know if it's legit you know
and they want to do something legit
about it fine you know and we'll see
what happens with that but at the same
time you know as far as I'm concerned
you know and shout King shots so child
you know gaming for me is near and dear
you know it's it saved my life I saved a
lot of my friends life on your King and
I and lost all we can attest you know we
grew up in the South Bronx and we could
have been doing a lot of other things
you know we changed the culture with
halo-halo changed the culture because
what what what you used to see before
was drug dealers on the corner right now
what we did was we took a group of our
friends I mean sure I can never say this
new much shout-out to mr. needle
Magneto's moms for allowing us to use
their house as our station and point
trust me because nowadays as a parent my
kids are not bringing 15 what the
influence was was we brought peripheral
friends in these peripheral friends went
back to the hood they introduced halo to
the hood then turn them to people
putting TVs on the corner to play Halo
and cable yeah that's before today's
xbox live baby you know groups would yo
my team again show team
I don't care they're betting money or
whatever it is it's taken away from
whatever they could be doing and they're
going into a positive place for
therefore to outlet you understand so I
can't see video games in the same light
as other people's talking about
travesties because all I see is
positivity coming from genre I choose to
enjoy and let me tell you this little
King just to expound on your point is
that was the argument you know shout out
to mama kognito
is it
- I mean listen a little pomade there's
like 15 to 20 of us over there every
Saturday you'll assay but at the end of
the day my argument was this and this is
how I want to / I said when I was
outside on the streets running wild you
didn't like that right
we would not you I wasn't coming home at
all type of hours of the night you
didn't like that I said I'm upstairs
with my friends you know where I'm at
and you know what I'm doing why are you
gonna stop me from that and that's how I
went over and she's know what he's here
yes what I they just keep the damn noise
down you know I mean she knew we was
doing something positive and we weren't
getting any trouble and that changed a
lot laughter you know shoutout to even
though we know a lot of people haven't
seen in a long time our Lord our Lord
can see all these people they told me
like yo if it wasn't for them Saturday's
kognito and coming out like you saved my
life could've been getting into all type
of foolishness and people would tell me
like yo I sometimes need to come over
just to get my mind off let's just bug
out let's get some halo going on can pop
in whatever it may be to get you out of
that negative and so on
I know I'm biased there's nothing no one
can tell me about video games you know
I'm saying I know the positive so she's
like well I think he was actually
telling the truth you said you got yes
RB was good oh yeah so also last week so
purchase events the head of the ESRB
made announcement indicating that coming
soon the ESRB was gonna add back of the
box laid
bullying to kind of alert customers to
the fact that that the game that
purchasing is gonna have in game
purchases alright okay and this is their
response to the whole loot crate
controversy that's been going on in the
past year so right the problem with it
is and again this is just my personal
opinion um it's too widespread
right a lot of people's problems with
loot crate are specifically with loot
crate's and nothing more and just like
the the predatory nature of what a loot
crate can be right these blind boxes
that you know you just keep putting
money into and you don't know what
you're necessarily getting out but it
preys on people's you know that
deficiency in people that makes you just
want to keep getting more and more and
more and so the issue with how the ESRB
is handling it is that it's it's too
widespread is too all-encompassing so it
doesn't focus on the loot crate's so
under the umbrella of this new
classification is all DLC oh my god so
basically you lump something everything
is if if any if within the game there is
a way to purchase anything and there is
you know a DLC content packs whatever it
may be
including loot crate's it's all under
the same umbrella so it doesn't identify
it specifically so the problem is it's
not addressing the problem it's
abandoned
yeah exactly took care of now not at all
not at all because it's just another
classification it's gonna be another
label on the back of a box that people
are not looking at and not caring about
um and it's not addressing the problem
more they might care about it because of
their label that might adversely affect
the video game that wouldn't have those
problems later on because they're
labeling because if let's say the parent
is aware of that and it says in-game
purchases is available in this game and
you know in the parent look at this back
of the box like oh no we can't do that
because you know Timmy just ran up my he
brought some apps off my phone I had a
lot I can't let this dude loose in these
streets so maybe that might adversely
affect the game having that label in the
back and it's not being
specific to what is you know purchasable
through that game that's exactly the
argument a lot of people arguing that
okay it's it's not addressing the
specific issue with with the stuff this
predatory right right and at the same
time what they're trying to do a it just
seems like it's it they're addressing
the biggest people politically who are
sort of so bossing about this you know
in order to try to shut them up right
right because they feel these people
like you know they bluster about they
talk about the stuff and then once
something is done they shut up they shut
up and end up and the argument goes away
right so the the perception is that's
one thing the ESRB is trying to do with
that right but um secondly it's the fact
that in a lot of ways it seems like
boxes sort of behoove the the gaming
industry absolutely and the belief is
that especially from the higher-ups at
companies that some way shape or form
these things have to exist in order to
create that secondary flow of money so
it's almost like they're trying to
protect it
right not singling it out well I mean
let me jump in real quick no I mean
let's be honest right the ESRB they're
just like self regulated body it's not
about a ESA so that Dec the ESA is gonna
work that's the people you know do III
and all that they're gonna work for the
publishers or oppose you didn't gonna do
from the consumer right they're gonna
protect that that group you don't say
they're kinda in cahoots
so to speak so it's not in their best
interest to go so hard let's be honest
on the process you know saying that's
revenue you know that kind of thing so
you know for me it's the same situation
like last time this is more like a you
know smoke a little cyber situation this
is not really address and it just sad
that now even if a game doesn't have
loot boxes if it has DLC in game
purchases it gets the label and one
thing that it's that I think and I hope
it works towards is like something what
King was talking about is like the
responsibility you should lie with the
parent always all of these systems have
things in place on on their own on their
networks parental controls that should
allow you to be
wouldn't keep your children from making
unwanted purchases on these games on and
on these systems either at the console
level or at the game level there these
things are all in place it's just a lot
of times parents are just like whatever
they don't pay attention to this right
you know what you need to pay attention
to this stuff you really do now to bear
defense I will say that they are
starting some website in the junction
with this for parents or something like
that and you know that's nice I'm saying
but let me look at what do you feel
about the whole ESRB situation uh to
tell you the truth I think I mean I
think they shouldn't do anything right
we already have ESRB ratings and we've
seen it at work inside the game stops
and other stores we see people the keys
try to go in and get the call of duty
and then the clerk kind of tells them
hey well you know I need your parent or
explain to their parent well this here
has yada yada yada so we've seen that
work right uh at the end of the day
people are gonna get what they want to
get in some ground form of fashion I'm
opposed to the government Stephanie and
do anything because they typically don't
do anything right anyway I think it's
one of those things especially regarding
the loot crate's and microtransactions
and all that stuff if people want to
spend money on these things
let him yeah I rarely ever spend a dime
an additional dime on the game that I've
already bought for 60 bucks unless I'm
buying DLC and DLC is totally different
other than that I just don't I just
don't deal with it so it doesn't affect
me but you know again it's it is kind of
getting ridiculous but who am I because
obviously these companies are making
billions and billions of dollars and
people are buying this stuff so hey you
know it is what it is yeah I mean I'm
with you Lord adequately what's your
feeling on this all the stuff when I
pass on which I think people have the
rights to you know do what they want to
do as far as their money but at the same
time you know if we're gonna do
quote-unquote regulation let's you know
do it right right you know I'm saying
and let's not play games with this whole
situation Lord King anything on us and
it looks awfully on topic
when y-you see my viewpoint on it my
viewpoint is the same um is I like DLC I
like to purchase play to win or whatever
I like to get the little horse that
nobody else has I mean Assassin's Creed
I put real money in today um and I don't
care if you don't want to do it nobody
put a gun in your head and say by that
DLC nobody said that so you don't buy it
you don't buy it and if you feel that oh
he has an advantage because he has this
then you buy it and if you can't afford
it cuz it sounds like a lot of people
that can't afford it or that's looking
for some free ride to get it no you're
not entitled to anything brother what
you entitled to do is put in your credit
card and purchase it if you choose if
not then try harder okay well I'm going
to do is I'm gonna put my I'm going to
get that package that comes in the
helmet you know because he hey excuse me
you got those amiibos with the work
like what quest is that did you got that
and he helps you out immensely oh yes
worse about that because I don't need
him I'm glad you did not need him but he
helped me along the way your wolf beat
the game and you didn't my wolf beat the
game he input all the presses he did
everything all did you get a special did
you get a special ending other than the
one I got interesting news that's been
popping off horizon zero dawn six
million and basically you know these are
crazy Killzone it's the most successful
first party franchise launch on ps4 to
date so it's just truly an exceptional
what it's been doing you know at least
obviously February of last year so it's
about a year old its own about 2.6
million first two weeks and three point
four as of June 2017 so I'm just wanted
to bring this to the Lords first you
know I got a lot of Sony a lot of Sony
news going on right now and it's
appropriate that we have no cradles on
so first of all Harrah's and adore the
success of it the fact is it was single
single play a game and all that
the second thing also want to talk about
is obviously we heard about Detroit B
becomes human game I had my eye on the
release date has been announced for
March 25th so that's gonna be a month
after Kratos is all God of War rollin
yeah then we got to piss Plus games
that's been announced and it's gonna do
blood-borne and Ratchet and Clank huge
games to be jumped into the earth blood
the kid smooth like it's like a side
from like they gave you God it's like
you gotta be blood-borne
it comes to breathe again one day he
makes this bad blood boards as a
PlayStation the place isn't gods is
[ __ ] and the last point I want to
make was on as far as placing news was
the young the Vita and the ps3 games
actually being discontinued from RPS
let's start off first with horizon zero
dawn we know it's a point of contention
here on the Isle of vodka well it's
great and you know when you wake up and
you piss excellence how long you take to
get this right you know what I'm not
gonna front
I am so happy that you actually saw that
10% that I've been asking for for ever
I mean weeks it took you two weeks to
sell two million it took us two days to
sell three it Park G um when I 10%
stands up ten percent really resonates
you know it's really a real 10 percent
down at was used to get you great
there's a great game I'm not gonna front
so check is that right so for what it's
not a shooter to is not on the shooter
box
so obviously it's gonna be a slow burn
it's not gonna be that fast you know on
the hype of 30 million PC gamers it's
not on a hype of that it's on its own
it's a standalone or the truth on its
own and it's good because you remember
the company have only ever made kills on
yes
and in killzone they spent all these
years trying to follow trying to chase
halo and it's like they they they needed
to give up on that right I know if it's
right
halo when this right is is on its own
and so you need to branch off and do
your own thing in this is what they came
up with and so this has solidified them
among the gaming gods and what they're
able to to do no this is good I mean in
obviously I think this game is gonna
keep selling is that's not going to stop
it's only been on the market for a year
it's gonna keep selling and it's a great
game it's a graphical showcase of what
station can do whether you have a pro or
slim is just one of those games that you
pop it in and people fade you know their
jaws are gonna drop it's just it is what
it is and you know shout out for them
for getting with Sony and saying hey we
want to do something something that's
different that's doing it we're not just
gonna copy and we're just not gonna
throw loot crate's and and all this
other stuff and there we just want to
make a good story based game in sonia
said that right this is this is what
they do this is their niche a focal
thorry driven games and this is another
one in a long line of story driven
narrative game so if they keep on that
path it's being successful for them so I
say you keep on maybe part two we may
get a multiplayer or something like that
but you know at the same time this is
nothing but great news I mean it's
absolute Lord addict I need your
feedback leaders just enough with that
first to success seven point six mil I
mean that's it's like I say over and
over again that's what happens when you
make good games it's those people keep
saying oh you only apply to the the cash
the if you don't apply to the casual but
you can't sell anything that games flats
you in the face and says you're wrong
like a good game you get good game money
that's just how it is we just make it
like that's why all these developers
that they want to make money like GTA
you you don't have a GTA product yes so
don't complain when you don't have a GTA
product that you didn't make GTA money
true Lord sovereign choruses in don't
what's going on I think any game that's
not GTA or Cod right would be
would kill to sell almost a million
copies in a year right no well that's I
mean it's amazing that it's done that
and like I said it's a quality product
it's gonna resonate one thing that's
always baffled me and this is on you
know on every console is the fact that
regardless especially on Sony like
Sony's looking at nearly 80 million
consoles sold and they've only sold
almost eight million this game which is
baffling to me but it happens all the
time it just seems like these for the
games it's the hard core who buys them
right and then the trickle-down effect
over the years you see more and more
purchases the price comes down and you
see more casuals buying them but like
that 10 million that all that 8 million
nearly 8 million that's that that's
hardcore people buying it mm-hmm it
baffles me that more people aren't
buying this game you know and just in
the same thing is true like I on Xbox
and the same thing is true on I think
all thing on switch is a little bit
different because Mario is such a
ubiquitous thing Mario was such a big
thing nobody knows a Lloyd Wright ya
know but Mario something to sells on so
many fronts today it's you know you'll
see those huge numbers um III think it's
amazing I'm excited to see what they
have in store for the next iteration of
it um there were things of the story
wise the game is fantastic I got a
little bored with with the with the
gameplay with that with the ear down of
the the dinosaurs
after a while but it's story wise hey
it's it's gonna be great and the thing
about it is also they also talked about
you know how they're doubling down now
even more on single-player stuff like
they're they're restructuring so needs
to focus even more on that so no I mean
if they're whipping ass right now like
it's gonna be crazy to see what they
focus on some you know going forward
yeah absolutely long working with
geminal it's going to jump in good ok
close up the drum they see everybody
hasn't been anticipating this topic
alright so the if they looked at the
topic sheet and they said whole cray
doses in there we came
we the same person so know what they
don't understand is okay um what
sovereign said is true um a lot of parts
you know it got tedious on certain
things right but what cradle said was
true as well it's a visual showpiece of
excellence for of the system now when
you're walking in the beginning of the
game and he's holding that baby like wow
yo this really looks good when that HDR
kicks in on your television and you see
this game and it's glory on that Pro I'm
not gonna lie this game was really made
for that Pro and it really sings to it
um the fact that they did sell those
numbers I'm happy for them because
they're showing again what other people
saying gaming instead is not dead gaming
is very alive brother and people out
here purchasing you know um a lot of
times you're gonna get my rents to the
point that okay you got 80 million sold
please sell 40 million games on one game
at least please do that that's my
thought and that's me being greedy yeah
because I have a horizon I have the game
I purchased so I'm part of the hardcore
debt purchase so I can talk crap about
my purchase but what I see is a lot of
times people don't give a game a shot
and they have negative comments about it
before they even play a game um play
game see what it has to offer enjoy it
if not sell it traded do whatever you're
gonna do with it but partake and what
your system has available for you and
this is one of the top-notch games and
I'm glad it has some form of success and
I hope that they sell 40 million I hope
that eight million is an indication of
it just keeps going all the way through
I mean it's pretty amazing I'm very
proud of it and I think what also can't
be understated it let's be honest you
know in horizion was the strong defense
like most of these other key this is a
true single-player game right mostly
other games have a multiplayer component
you know that Connor has been the
driving force of the generation to help
generally sell your friends apart
like that so to see this title succeed
like that
similar tile in the Zelda vein you know
single player title succeeding
it's amazing shout out to those guys you
know I'm saying guerilla games and again
the huge thing like cradles said they
were allowed to do something else and as
Microsoft fans we already screamed for
that right we want them to do all to
have the studios do other when he told
they do or when they do something
different they say yours is so bad now
that literally made no sense
I completely agree it's just funny how
you don't say sometimes the Exile
community reacts when you know the stuff
that they supposed what is being done
and then it's a complain for that you
know but shout out to playground games
and we're hearing it you know they may
or not be do you know behind the other
fable next Fable series good to see you
know I'm saying it's good to see you
know the continued success of that so as
far as the other parts to the
PlayStation news reasons we talked about
the Detroit already yeah March 25th I
think that's good back to back I want to
get into these PS plus games because I'm
there's a lot of shout out to attic all
just move the cruel at planning Xbox
Merc you know I'm saying jazz all y'all
frog I was listening to y'all y'all was
going in on that a PS Plus you know
there was a big debate obviously in
reference to the game's quality you know
versus the games for gold so I want to
get into that because obviously we seen
what Bourne rankings and the second
thing is about the Vita and ps3 games
being discontinued and how we feel about
that so Lord cradles our guest what do
you feel about that whole comparison you
know with the services and Vita and PSP
games when it comes to the Vita and in
other old games I'm like I think after
it's been it's been long enough right
it's time for some of that stuff to go
away you right now they're focusing on
the future I mean there's a lot of
people who sit here and they try to
hold on to the past and it's like that's
kind of part of the the issue that
Microsoft had this generation was it was
xbox360 guys that kept playing and
holding on to their 360 and it's like
it's time to let that go and focus on
the new stuff yeah and it's the same
thing with that I think you know again
it's all opinionated I say that stuff
off let it go nobody if you if you don't
have that stuff by now come on are you
doing it I'm good I'm that gamer show me
the new stuff so then what up now what
about where you at with the let's get
let's get fanboy yes you little it's a
reflection of how this generation has
turned out you're looking at the wrong
free stuff we're dazzling you with the
jab we're hitting in the mouth with the
jab and the delante while the right hand
is coming over the top of the game
that's the real game pass is good I've
always say a game pass is great I can
have all your games for $10 I'm never
mind another PlayStation game ever again
thank you Microsoft for that you've
saved me so much money I bought to see
if thieves right a bossy of these
pre-ordered it so does they announce get
all these brand-new games everything is
gone
going to game pass council my council
people cancel the pre-order like that's
because I bought it on the on the you
know on the Xbox store so I bought
yesterday got no money back you can do
it but I got a bigger like for that
particular mobile like don't let no
these people do it
PlayStation for some reason they won't
even let you refund pre-orders because
he notices popping but he like three or
four hundred dollars worth of stuff
because they were supposed to change his
email the last time that he talked to
them because he got locked out of his
PSN account and they did it they just
unlocked it for him or he can get in it
and he just bought a pro and he sold as
a his regular ps4 and he cannot get into
his account and they called and they
said well there's nothing we can do
about you but what is my office like
that dude straight up dead no let live
man
so start another PSN I do about all this
stuff my boy he said no lie you got the
bite again unbelievable if you were good
oh you're good I'm good man again this
this month games for gold versus you
know course PSA yes sir mean this is
just food is on a neck is just yeah this
is the body man I keep saying this over
and over
Sony's seat backs in wait for Microsoft
to make a move and being Sony comes out
in punch them in the back of the head
all this all these rumors about them
buying studios and doing all this stuff
that comes out and everybody's talking
about it and being Sonia come on come
and catch them off guard and you know
push them down or some I mean Sony just
with the release date it's like
Microsoft just can't catch a break and
Sony not letting them get any
smoke and mirrors shouting thank you
guys yeah it does like they gave you a
backhanded compliment they did these two
games this month but we're taking away
[Music]
okay he knows this and he's hoping that
y'all fall for the spoken mirrors he
knew he was getting four games a month
and now is down to two good games is
coming out because Microsoft has given
out for so any kid that knows math I
don't care how good you games is
Forrester a d12 ah I'll take the to the
holodeck give me them for me it's free
right
supposedly what do you have to say about
the they've been given six games away
for like for like a minute into the days
every month actually get online to play
like a month so you needed to have a
switch I understand why he has all those
gigs damn straight
anytime we go down I'm stress which
bound or I'm gonna get on the Xbox
listen let me tell you let me tell you
when PSN does go down guess what it
doesn't affect us you know why because
we have a plethora losses that will take
do you think that is shitty and playing
because they know that they these
services is crap and you're gonna be
alone a lot you think that they say
we're not going to focus on multiplayer
because we can't sustain and so they
give you one player games here's a
better question for Ukraine is that the
reason they don't let you change your
gamertag is you don't interact with each
other cuz you're all
you just but at a today
they they will not bundle their great of
the greatest IPS and some and thrift
store prices that's what happens when
you're coming in from the rib that's
what happens when the leader is so far
ahead you have to do safari things that
make people take notice of you I'm sorry
you know it's a fact
you have to listen if we was winning we
wouldn't be doing this
thank you right so agree right will we
agree if Microsoft wasn't in the
position at their end we wouldn't be
getting game passed we will no but I
mean there's a lot of people that
believe that Microsoft cares about me
this is why they're like if they cared
about you you've been kind of you know
asking them to give you all these games
and to do this and do this fight back
fight back fight back and then feel
special becomes the Hayward kumbaya
we're here and only has some great games
I love those Nintendo has some great
games I love those and it's not
reciprocated back because this is what's
great about this competition at the end
each day it benefits gamers with Sony
doing well Microsoft has to go extra
hard during the ps3 era when 360 was
doing well you know I'm saying Sony
would not be in a position that they're
in if Microsoft and Nintendo hadn't
pushed them to do with their bags
absolutely Louis Saha we gotta get you
idiot man yeah man all right so my my
thing is really a question right well
I'd this week this month the FPS plus is
no there's no question that PS plus is
on the neck I mean if I didn't own both
of those games already I mean losing my
mind um
my thing is this so they eventually
they're gonna remove ps3 and Vita from
this and they announced no replacement
and this is the thing that bothers me
about it right so okay so you're telling
people already you know what and it
bothers me minimally some people are
more angry about this and but the thing
about it is you're telling me okay
you're giving me the same service mm-hmm
less with less games now and you didn't
announce a replacement and what I mean
by replacement is there was no they
didn't say you know what we're gonna put
a PS VR game in there right I mean they
could very well be counseling ps4 games
as psvr mm-hmm what it is sort of his
own thing like the most part if it's a
PS VR game you're gonna need psvr to
play you're not it's not a game that you
can play on ps4 by itself so it should
be its own separate thing so the fact
they didn't say hey we're gonna throw
psvr on there and it's a little weird to
me cuz it to me you know as well as
they've done with psvr
I would think you wanna you know give
people the incentive to go out there and
buy that headset if you're given my free
games for it every month you know and I
don't have it yet I'm gonna want to buy
the headset right mmm-hmm just just to
piggyback off what you're saying what's
up cuz I know where you're going with it
and this is part of something where I
was gonna go to is also do we feel like
in this age is digital age right where
everything we get these free game games
go game past yada yada yada
um I know for I agree with all Kratos in
a sense I know for the most part
everyone wanna you don't want to take on
the bran table today is not playing ps3
and Vita games like that let's just say
that right now but at the end of the day
like these are services that were
promised and what we feel about in this
digital age with things getting
discontinued because that's the argument
again for the physical guys against the
digital guys like don't own that so at
the end of the day if Sony Microsoft
anyone shuts down those services you're
done you don't have access to this game
so I want to know what does the
roundtable Lords feel about that aspect
as far as ownership and services going
away it's a little scary because when
you look at I'm sorry you want to go
ahead like are you talking about like
games of gold and stuff like that you
know I'm just talking about like in that
series of games with gold they would
probably relinquish all the all the
rights to those games unless you own
them I feel like that's the own
way that they could get away from that
mm without a backlash yeah I mean I
think the worry with Sony especially
with Sony is they haven't made it clear
that moving forward they're gonna be
doing this stuff right so with ps4
anything you get for ps4 as at this
point you can assume that it's gonna
stay there and it's not moving with you
whereas Microsoft has already said like
that's not what's happening so you have
a little more confidence in that
ecosystem and being happy you know
having that stuff moving forward so I
think what Sony it's a little more
worrisome because they haven't been
clear about what they want to do with
that right my assumption is they have to
do it but I you know they could do
whatever they want you know it could
very well be in the same thing with
Nintendo like I've gone pretty much all
digital on switch saying in in the hopes
that Nintendo you know gets it but you
know more than anybody else I don't know
that Nintendo gets it so it's like you
know what happens you know with the next
console fax it's log king you want to
jump in hard you know it's like this is
hard because I feel sorry for the
PlayStation 3 dudes that didn't make the
jump that was counting on these games
you know and I have my Vita like I said
this is right next to me I'm bi I do
physical with the Vita so that the
digital didn't bother me my PlayStation
3 it doesn't bother I don't buy them so
and I don't download those games for my
on PSN actually I don't even have PSN to
be honest with you
I got it that month when I played a
shout out the hip hop gamer I logged in
right there
got the game downloaded the game like
that that's what real men do there about
that smoke hollow man bang bang that's
what real men do or they don't run and
hide to have other men handle a business
form
what um again this this stuff is so
distant from me but I can empathize with
those people that utilize this service
and they look for those games
so like addict said um like in the
future if they was to get rid of games
of gold with the relinquished those
thing ah hell no I don't think so
they're gonna look at you and say well
you no longer have access to those
contents we let you hold that there was
a lady I think you would just depend on
how and why it happened yeah like what
would what would precipitate that to
happen in that nature but again back to
what they did and what is being lost
thing like sovereign said they need the
form of replacement it would be great
for VR because then I can get a couple
of more VR games that I don't normally
have and use it a little bit more um I'm
too chicken crap to play by myself in
the house team around me because you
isolated in that world brother I'm
talking now mom but yeah they all would
be nice as a good replacement that
actually would encourage me to get it if
they actually included if they replace
that with that with one of those games
be honest I just me think what you think
look girls where does the stereo is mics
down there right what do you think about
VR I think they threw that in no I mean
like I said they I'm kind of surprised
that they didn't announce a replacement
immediately and VR makes the most sense
unless you know unless at some point
they're gonna cut that off which I hope
I certainly hope not because my thing is
I know I said at the end of last year I
was getting it you know I was in ER and
you know I don't know how many times I
was on the Amazon page how many times I
was physically in the store ready to buy
it and I something told me you know what
I think there's an update coming out
this year I want to be untethered like I
don't want to deal with the wire so I
didn't pull the trigger and my hope is
that we get a you know a 2.0 version
that's Wireless at some point um that's
really what I want
okay can I can I tell you why that's not
gonna happen jumping okay as an owner of
I was a day one adopter of the oculus so
sorry cut you're gay look I just laugh
reminds me of King
so I understand what about this right
I'm
you you can't go wireless because you
have to think about addition your safety
the wires tether you and keep youth in a
certain safe perimeter if it's wireless
right you start swinging you're gonna
hit somebody you're gonna hit something
you're gonna hurt yourself in the
liability goes on the company um we need
something that has barriers it has to
have a physical barrier all of us have a
huge garage where we can set this up and
just be you know just just free of this
stuff you have to have a certain you
know I don't know if it's a mat that
they put down or something there's gonna
have to be some if they decide to do the
whole wireless deal it's I can see why
wires is is there it's there for your
safety but it's also through the because
of the data is such high rate these
things are running at a minimum of 90
frames per second back in yeah so you
gotta realize to check that goes behind
instead you know it kind of it is what
it is but I hear people say I'm just
gonna wait for it to go wireless I'm
like and you know where you're gonna be
waiting a long time most of us are lazy
right most of people I don't have VR
they want to be sitting in the chair
sitting on the couch playing fear they
don't want to be up there you know over
there's a box again yes we are
it's like Mike Tyson's punch-out yeah
it's a punch shot it's such a workout so
after you finish if you ain't been
working at me you're gonna be sore
you're gonna be sweating and everything
else but if this thing was Wireless man
you're gonna be me punching you know
freakin easy do you remember the first
initial videos of the we when people was
strapped into if you are loose in the
living room with this thing on ahead
[Music]
he said getting close he said the
amorous demo VR headsets what 1440p rent
when T it is the Microsoft ones are
wireless
you know the PC ones right the ones that
they showed at CES show so we'll have
the internal tracking and alternate
right that's what they're they're
allowing another company to develop and
push that out and yeah yeah they make
the games I think that's the smarter
move but what Sony is controlling
controlling is the narrative of how they
PSR is psvr is presented to the public
and I think they're doing a great job at
being ambassadors towards that
gatekeeper type of thing yes Sony does a
lot of things first as well it's not
just Microsoft and I'm very happy that
they did this because also I'm a
proponent of VR I think everybody should
try it at least once to see if they like
it because it's a different genre of
what we love in this medium yeah
absolutely absolutely I just want to
finish up when I started on yeah man I
think a lot you guys all knocked it out
the park you know as far as the listen
as far as the DVD and ps3 stuff I
definitely you know just raised my
eyebrow a little bit I understand why
you know saying but again if the quality
of the games of gold
I mean PS bus is going to stay at that
level I don't know if you can maintain
it that would be great we'll see what
happens with that and yeah you know
that's all I've pretty much got on that
unless any Lords got on this topic
yeah I want to add to it a little bit
like what I mentioned before about how
now made the statement how they're
restructuring internally in to sort of
focus even more on first party stuff and
like what what do you guys think about
that like what does that mean moving
forward for like a third party deals
that they have with Call of Duty and
Activision and destiny like do they are
they saying they're you know come next
gen maybe that those deals aren't in
place and also like what is how does
Microsoft react to that Alice Nintendo
react to that like that because this end
we're gonna double down on what we do
best right finally
that's kind of nuts man like I mean
because their first party second party
output is already crazy as it is mm-hmm
absolutely you got a look at that and I
agree I mean I jump in
III was pretty amazing for them to even
come out and make that statement there
it is is identity you know saying I
think that's the Sony ego says Knox
that's what they do you know I mean when
you when I watch a Sony trailer watch a
spider-man like they're just good at
presenting these great narrative pieces
you know you sitting in that's what as
an xbox guy I have to say I really enjoy
watching so many conferences only
because I guess I don't know if it's the
movie background the cinematic nature
they know how to present you know they
they definitely know how to present
great graphical showcases and
powerhouses they have and that is
something that is unmatched just
generation absolutely that's the only
thing I wish Microsoft would take a
piece from I'm saying because at the end
of the day you can say what you want but
it's like people believing them
conferences all emotional private party
I made the mistake to say that uh I
think Sony being in the movie industry
helps drastically make better games and
people have no that's not true
play okay tell me those set pieces of an
uncharted isn't movie expired yes like
when localized we when it was history
and he talked about that God of War
right I was in III we was we was at III
whiskey and we sat there and we watched
it make days gone like me incognito
we're talking to him at a private
showing when they're showing the game at
e3 and he was like was like sorry you
guys a new studio this dude straight
looked as we've been making games for
Sony for like 15
it is shows it again fanboy knows
nothing it's just facts is facts you
have to give credit where credit is due
and just that's their strength and and I
I'm not mad like whatsoever saying that
they're gonna continue to double down on
it that's what their identity is to me
that's and I'm not mad at xbox but game
passing and and put it if you look at
like to see if thieves and a lot of
these multi player games are in there
right that's their ecosystem that's
their strength you know I'm saying
people double down on what you do you
know I'm saying that should think but
what did all the loss think about that
more be what you are and stop trying to
be something you not trying to be
something you're not
it's not a king boss you'll stand on
those two toes you sit down all right
to the game I love the fact that Sony is
definitely gonna be them and Microsoft
is doing them in Nintendo oh I just I
think to me is one of those things were
but we've seen that this particular
narrative has done very well for them so
it's just one of those things where the
other the other two got a look at it and
be like alright man we really have to
like up our game in this aspect because
this is what what's gotten Sony again we
talked about identity
this is Sony's identity through and
through and the fact that they're just
making sure that that shines through
more than anything else it to me the
other two got to really look at it and
be like hey man we got a we got to
double our efforts to yeah we if you
take a look at Nintendo right they have
carved in their child they said look we
don't want to compete with the big with
the big pie in 4k and all the specs and
stuff this is what we do well we do hand
hails we do the the cartoony type stuff
this is this is where we're gonna stay
we're gonna this is who we are this is
what we're gonna focus on to the inner
key let's be real
loke they're like y'all don't care what
they do our Pokemon house has all their
plaques that's the truth in their own
lane and and but I do feel like
Microsoft this generation they will have
lost what they were and would created
how they were last generation how they
dominate it they have lost that they
have no sense so now they're like over
here they're over there they're still
trying to find their identity and I
think they've made some strives to try
to reshape themselves but Microsoft Xbox
is not the Xbox in the Microsoft of
yesterday of the companies that of the
company that we remember they're they're
just not right some people can say
that's for the better some people say
that's for the worse I don't know I'm
not gonna judge that but it is what it
is but you have half the people begging
for Microsoft to do things the way they
did last generation then you have the
other half
accepting of everything that they
present going forward for the future
right now the big question mark is where
are we going with this thing we know
that they've made a bunch of change they
put some games on PC they got game as
they're going there on a streaming
service that they're working on mm-hmm
what's the e game for this they're
trying to prep right now and one of
those no no a necessary part good
question you actually leading us into
the next topic which is addicts topic as
far as obviously what's been going on
all these rumors what they make sense of
it and where do we think on so let's
push that into addicts topic Matic where
you at with this whole situation I know
you wanted to talk about that oh I mean
it's it's it's pretty clear there's a
lot of stuff going on with Microsoft we
go from a year of nothing no one talks
about it no was talking about anything
Microsoft related to Microsoft's by EA
Microsoft by and Steve lying pub G
Microsoft making this video like
Microsoft's buy it Sega like any of
these we believe we believe or do we
like believe none of them like I'm
curious what everyone is let's stop
myself get some yes sir what as far as
the room
nobody said like I was chopping at the
bit like I really like that they'll just
say like you know as far as the first
part which is you know cradles point
which is where do you think Microsoft is
going with their recent actions and then
b2 up Attucks point as far as the whole
rumors that you actually believe yeah I
mean to me why I think they're going is
again this unified ecosystem thing where
at some point in the future and who
knows how far in the future that is
we're looking at Microsoft being an
ubiquitous thing all over the x-box
should I say Microsoft over it is that
you you big with this thing but um you
know Xbox as being a brand that's
everywhere and they'll have their own
hardware and they'll be happy to have
you play on that or they'll be happy to
have you play on whatever down the line
um I think that's the end game
ultimately you know however many years
down the line that is long so I think we
don't we're not hearing about that
because it's you know I think Phil is
well aware of the the damaging power of
forcing people to do something they're
not ready to do though this it's gonna
be a slow burn we're gonna see
improvements on the ecosystem front with
Xbox with the X and whatever comes after
the X and I think it's just gonna be a
slow progression towards that towards
that unified ecosystem type of thing
yeah um and what was the second part
just in reference to which action rumors
that you actually believe if any that
women with Bailey it's been valve it's
been a it's been saying this I
completely slim but you know be like the
most hilariously
because I'm all about the world party
like at e3 that Microsoft all these
rumors are true that'll be great that'll
be great for Scott
phil has said that he's looking to buy
buy stuff right but Dan when to get win
that when people that make sense like
respawn needed to be bought they didn't
act Capcom was struggling they needed
some help they they had they had
alternative motives they're like really
hope we would you buy a piece of the
store where you can just buy the store
die just store I want your store okay so
let me ask you this come III right none
of that stuff happens I'm sure I'm just
saying I could I'm just happens then are
we gonna be sitting around talking about
world it was a great distraction you
know I'm saying it's like it's time to
put up or shut up shut up y'all need to
maintain the level that you're doing
you're doing great at doing it what
we're doing is we're doing things to to
secure the future into the next
generation listen you are 8-1 is that
the referee comes in they separate the
two combatants you won your hand is up
looking into positions I hear you hmm
hey your heartbeat sounds like sasquatch
what does that mean for us see
everything turns out - what did that
mean for us what Bonnie did was sunny so
they looking to buy stuff what we gotta
do is we're gonna do what we do best so
we're gonna develop more of our stuff
right yeah smoke and mirrors hmm this is
what I'm trying to say maybe none of
this stuff comes to pass maybe most of
it comes to pass
like attic said I'm in a part of maybe
it all happens because some people said
before they
Disney World Marvel will never acquire
all the assets nobody saw Disney coming
and purchasing Marvel my whole money in
the back now
mm-hmm my pockets is fat now mmm is
about to go down there and not a whole
MCU who's pretty much they got him no
you know it might end up happening
because Warner Bros and then just sounds
far-fetched right but all that other
stuff was far-fetched to mmm Warner
Brothers is gonna be a facility second
yeah what happens if Disney buys them
nobody says don't know that guys are not
gonna happen
all right okay I'm just saying this
right with the smoke this fire we all
know that mmm we come from this game and
stuff that we used to hear things and
Blake now that's not what I'm say two
things you know I'm just I'm just
I just gotta be I just got to keep it
real keep it all away for one I think
it's Microsoft even in thousand years
can never be Sony a video game that's my
first thing my second thing is even if
Microsoft made all these moves and
bought all these games Microsoft is
about money right there they're they're
about business they are not gonna keep
it just for the 35 million install base
they have they want that and they will
be able to tap into their 8080 you know
78 to 80 million PlayStation fan base
and tin dough is coming up pretty slim
and PC Microsoft is is is a big I mean
they're they're looking at take it all
but it's not I think I think Xbox guys
need to stop thinking that Microsoft
really cares about these small lecture
and they care about the big picture
let's say they oh they do buy these
companies
hey let's theoretically said that they
looking for the long turn out the short
run they tried to make money in the long
run not in a couple years we're talking
about five to ten years and they did
make all this Windows on Steve and Xbox
exclusive and kept it off the
PlayStation brand what do you think
would happen
drastic impact you are highly mistaken
right I can see Microsoft double in
their install basin in a year I'm seeing
do you do you I don't think every one of
those not gonna play Madden everyone
over on PlayStation is not going to play
all the they go into the brand that has
okay yeah
Kratos what I was saying like you
Ellis trait at my point perfectly
Microsoft wants it all they want that
install base so why not be real with the
rumors like you know like you set it up
properly that if I want to make a real
change a real impact you take away the
ammo out of the gun from the opposite
person so they can't shoot those bullets
at you so no matter for you know this
for you know that for you know this for
you and then what then you have to rely
on your in-house Sony is not Nintendo
they can't survive no this is bare
minimum I get that but all I'm saying is
they did it would be devastating to the
PlayStation right now a little bit it
would be devastating how many EA games
would make a year literally you're
taking probably 25 to 30%
I agree the impacts on it but I agree
cradles as well great they have not
shown that they are going to do that
exclusive route like remember when they
got
rise of the Tomb Raider just for
exclusivity so Phil shown based on his
patterns that he is not about keeping
content and stuff exclusively he's not
even one is that we are doing that the
impact it would have
[Music]
absolutely you know if I'm just asking
for Microsoft hey deliver me some
quality games that are graphical
showcases for your platform like Sony is
doing for theirs that's all I'm asking
for you haven't provided that for me
what makes me think that you're gonna go
and do some big major money move
difference between then and now someone
else in your spot and Phil Spencer has a
seat at the table I think that's gonna
get money for like EA purchase but I do
think that's gonna bring a lot more
revenue to the Xbox brand like Kratos go
dance-off jumping yeah okay so I want to
say this it's been five it's been five
years now I feel Spencer was not a rat
there next next was standing right next
to Donnie D the only thing I feel were
you going and you you like you it's five
years I mean this what if what if
garbage I feel like all I'm gonna say
the only thing I gotta give attic Incan
King this is that this is the first time
Phil is in position even when he was
missing mattress I mean he didn't have
any took the lead of marketing nicely to
March
in a circle at the table now like he's
in the more if that's the only reason
why I said let me see this year cuz I do
agree with you don't get me wrong
they've been talking a lot and there's a
lot of this room is here and all that
I'm of the same mindset of you are like
I need to see cuz all I've been hearing
is what if what if you know saying that
comment I just want to see what he does
now that he's in position because it's
clear that he's in position is so far I
mean let's be honest this first year
2018 we've had more positive news in
these first three months than all of
2017 2017 we called it the Lord's we
called it officially considering
continued great Oh Saint continue adding
so when Mike when he came into power it
was like the beginning of last year the
end of the year before that he did give
out a road map he said I'm working on
services then hardware then first party
games that was his exact sentence he
state he stay behind that phrase this
entire generation that he actually took
over the brand now if you look at what
he's did game pass Xbox one X now we're
having a [ __ ] ton rumors about first
party exclusives we're gonna the execs
these that sit-ins that he said past a
past came out we heard rumors about the
X the X came back now wherever rumors
about first party [ __ ] but here's the
thing right is I don't know but this
feels Minister is the same guy that said
games like horizon zero dawn and Zelda
don't cut it like they used to in Seoul
listen to this man he didn't say it some
crazy like that it goes back to what it
used to means like all of that happiness
I think he needs to say it's not for us
in our platform not a long when Germany
when it come together
how many zeros have we go
longevity is dead real here the top 10
selling games every month rarely have
these games in it
Carranza did fantastic but still you see
GTA 5 on the top you seriously
challenged on the top you don't see
these mad play over walkie and then you
see they were at the occasional like
Zelda good luck on three or four but I
do see I do see Kratos as point insane
like host you don't say that
blanket statement with his yard I can't
do y'all over here what I would say to
you is we've been down in this
generation for so long any positive
words or encouragement to foster stand
up cuz you know you know so if there's
any type of light at the end of the
tunnel we're gonna hold on to that now I
look if we look at my gamertag is MIA
Phil yeah right and he's the realest
exact that I have come in contact with
if he speaks it he tries not he uses the
even tone he he's more about inclusion
anyway a dent exclusion so if he
actually did purchase EA I'm pretty sure
all those games would still be on
everybody system anyway you know um I
don't think that it will go in a
narrative of dictatorship as far as I
think there may be one or two studios
that they I think I do think anthem
would end up being exclusive would do
that as spite from Bungie in destiny
could be but of us being beaten in the
head like you said back of the head get
punched back hey it was funny as hell to
me you're right
and I just see it as you know let us get
a little bit of sunshine on our back son
you get even standing in the Sun for a
moment you know your soul seven a
million eight
look like Xbox guys wish it all the
stuff King little King man alright thank
you for putting it in that way man I'm
good like you real man you you a real
brother serious business you you you you
say that where a lot of other people
wouldn't have said that but you try
actually right when you see a number one
you see a number one you don't see a
number four or five or anything else
right out there that's what we've been
saying this like this whole generation
but it's like it's guys out there that
are just in denial about that you know
you know who's the market leader when
you look at your stuff but you also know
who you play with yeah so my famine is
'm is it's going to be towards xbox i
play with these guys all these guys in
this chat i play with them yeah
you understand we play on xbox it could
be easily he's playing on playstation
but that's not what we play it we put
our Xbox so of course I'm gonna
gravitate towards that because when I go
downstairs I pick up that controller so
of course I want them to win that's the
horse I bet on that's nice that doesn't
mean that's the horse that's supposed to
win I'm not entitled to anything honest
with you people keep saying like so
Microsoft needs to try to do it what
Sony's doing that though they try the
reason they start - what made the 360
what it was like the best multiplayer
experience you could possibly have with
like single play explain our experiences
splashed into the generation they were
doing way better than they are now
what's the last no system so they had
titanfall
what's the last one besides that G
they're the biggest multiplayer they
should double down and she'll shut up
the lava on the chat he just made a
great point he said I generally think
that owning all the consoles really does
open your eyes to a lot of things and
it's true and I think a lot of let's
beer a lot of the families double xp all
got our favorites we're not gonna deny
that but a lot of it is because do say
look
let's keep it real I only got enough
bread for one of these system so they'll
be like you know I gotta make an
informed decision on what imma buy so
once you make that decision that's the
horseshoe bet on so low-key those people
going to feel away if the side they
didn't pick it'll say it succeed and I
think a lot of it that's how it you know
it gets into this whole people not being
real about himself you know I'm saying
that's one thing you know Leslie least
try to strive on and shout out to King
for saying what he said and cradles for
baking them up because it's like oh we
know what's going on here we're not
stupid we just choose this our favorite
platform yes we choose the Gateway this
the ecosystem that we like but at the
end of day we're not gonna disrespect so
let's see yeah they got the boot on a
neck it's obvious this generation it is
it is what it is my whole point to the
hole bigger wrong a picture to your
initial question cradles is that I think
it's what you said that Xbox realizes
this I mean this is the long game setup
for the next generation in the services
in place get this game path get you
notice they've really doubling down on
backward compatibility bringing the
whole library full you know and and then
they also realize to King's point the
power narrative was killing them right
so they like Dave I think filler this is
my opinion
I just feel Phillips made a conscious
decision we can never be behind those
digital foundry vision as we see how
let's be real digital foundry is the
voice of this generation I don't care
what nobody say people tune into them
videos and you see how many peas and how
many chains and I would frame and people
feel the way decisions to kind of use
that re up reload and get ready for the
next generation
so what would restaur lord's cradles
solve got a bet you can't beat him by
[Applause]
and I just think I think as Xbox heads
we just want them to be more competitive
in that face and they haven't been like
Kratos said like they just haven't lived
up to that like me and it did just need
to be more competitive in that space
give us more um you know yes they've had
some bad luck in terms of games they've
had to cancel or whatnot this is more
enough to the quality if they wanted it
happens anyway you know like I said was
phoning me you know as long as some a
lot of their games take to come out they
come out whenever however long it takes
and that matters that gives people a
confidence especially the hardcore gives
them a confidence in those brands I'm
and that's something that that the
people that were once lawyer Xbox don't
see anymore
oh that's true yeah great
it's a tiller the to takes right if
you're an Xbox guy and you feel like
they haven't given you what you want it
a lot of people have jump ship and it's
crazy when I went out when I say that
because it's like why would a person
jump ship all it takes is for you to
spend $1.99 they go get your PlayStation
or switch or whatever and then just have
the best of both worlds you know this
big buffet so when they do come out with
game set you like you already there yeah
I think it's just you know it just kind
of it's just like playing football right
you got your favorite football team you
like man team you hate everybody those
team you don't want to be like I hate
the Cowboys I mean so first half of my
family's divided so I could care less
hope they never win another game that's
how this the with video games that's how
it's become it's not always been that
way but it's there's always been a
rivalry
I think that they could have been little
things with these first parties that's
flock that could have made them a lot
better
like I just I understand that you know
that concept well the third party does a
multiplayer but it's like you weren't
built off that frame like your
foundation was built off a multiplayer
you literally through the entire gaming
industry to an online revolution
why and then like why like the time that
you are down the most you start throwing
out like not above average single-player
games but like average to a little above
average it's like little things like
making for us sunset overdrive for
player co-op the whole story could have
done could have been human could be
things by you know like actually giving
recore a budget could have made one huge
relevant impact little things like
buying respawn to keep titanfall you
know instead like you know you you go by
with the manure you want and not the
majority you like you built your entire
foundation of multiplayer games and then
you start throwing out like you can't do
it like Sony unless you're gonna throw
out Sony quality single-player games yes
you're not like not even a little bit
pub G's been the first game in a long
time that I that they are starting to
make good decisions again for each look
at scalebound
like thank God that game didn't come out
because that would have been a huge flop
on the Xbox Brad well you have all like
the what the Thoth the ten total people
on on Twitter like oh my gosh it came
out it will flopped and then and then
they would be saying they don't want to
even invest leave even it's it's better
for it to flock without the consumers
making it flop yes because if the
consumers made it flop investable like
yo we keep putting up money made by
nothing yeah yeah we got a red but we go
to look on one more topic he's gonna
finish up with a Lord King I know what's
going on today you still want to touch
on the battle that's going on with the
battle royal real quick
well main for whatever-your-name-is
scalebound is a completely different on
a monster world is in a completely
different world in scale bell like that
franchise has been developed for like
how long like the past 10-15 years let's
say just because monster world
Mott's 400 worlds when scalebound was
going to automatically do sure because
it wasn't I can almost be reward it was
different though it was something that
we know just was looking forward to it
you don't try to make different stuff
when you're not appealing to the
majority you can't say that only doing
his halo fors and gears all day but
every day if every game you papa that's
fiery and you selling crazy amounts
think you can start to well okay you
know they be the majority of our friends
like this will still give them stuff
like this to keep them happy let's try
to get everyone else to young in the
youngest stuff you take a risk when you
fall in or do you take a risk when you
stand him mmm even way is a choice that
you're gonna have to make and you know
as the captain of the ship whoever was
running the ship at that period of time
they decided that they wasn't gonna take
a risk on certain titles at this point
in time they have all the assets they
own everything so when you own something
that means you use it at your disposal
why use that bullet right now when it's
not necessary in a losing cause they
lost shout out the Santoni setup assume
everyone has played ashen and last look
I'm all about diversity in the title I
don't want them to stop doing that yes
double down on your strengths do you I'm
saying but my thing is why can't we do
both
exactly you lose market share even more
and more your investors become less so
it's harder to do diversifies when you
keep trying to branch out to different
genres and losing more and more money
because you're not my point
I'm also would be money on this in check
but every success there should be at
least a risk there should be one risk if
you've eaten or some at least try
because my thing is if that game wasn't
all the way successful that brought in a
different type of gamer to your platform
you know I'm saying that's what you got
to look at at the end of the day yeah it
didn't it's like we complaining when you
know horizon whatever whatever but seven
point six people was like yo I'm feeling
this that's not all of the so needs base
it's like it's like this guy's you got
to realize right and in order to be
successful you have to have a large
install base now not everybody in your
star base is gonna buy
one type of game right you got to look
at like the playstation yeah they have
76 78 million gamers
but they have a diverse I mean I got
fries that only play Japanese RPGs
they're not fries that still only play
Madden in 2k every on another game small
they offer look at a game like um I mean
just just look at their lineup of games
right the story driven games you know
it's just all these different games that
you that you can you know gravity rush
just all kind of different art styles
and type of games that they can have and
that is why people even if they've never
really gained in the past and they come
on there now they say hey I'm into Nier
automata it looks like a cool game let
me let me do that and that's the
platform that it offers and so we're if
you're interest into shooters and racers
do this is why people say xbox is for
you for them because they cater to that
particularly crowd but I think I think
it's okay for you to cater that crowd
but you have to in order to grow your
install base you have to reach out to
the PlayStation fans and the Nintendo
fans you just can't stay in your little
bubble and just you gotta reach out at
all times you must you know extend your
reach you cannot be secure in their
little bubble there's more could his
final copy the fans have been waiting
for Lord King on this one the chat is
lit it's the hottest thing in the street
right now it's the battle royale Lord
King what's going on with this these pub
g4 day streets was good I promise you
that I'll bring this type of guys um
it's come to my attention there for
tonight has decided to Double Down
4k 60 frames a second um Xbox 1x
enhanced title day on this season 3 mmm
my question to
congregation to the people stand into
the round table to the pulpit in anybody
listening across this nation Church has
the student surpassed the master it was
a period of time with pomp G look like
it was an unstoppable monster then this
free game came out yes it stole all its
life now you know that the the free game
is for tonight you know my whole
contention has always been if it wasn't
free nobody be playing it um maybe you
get trickle hair trickle there is at
four or five million I don't think so
now you know every person is playing pop
G pay for that is not true when you go
to fortnight but did that model help
them surpass pop G pop G just released a
4k update and a stable of framerate and
a lot of fixes to what was going on and
the questions that was going on both of
these games are in preview but they both
got in there and it seems to be one has
flourished using a different model the
other one has flourished using a
different model but which one has
surpassed the other one at this point in
time let's go this is the hottest Kratos
let's go okay so here's the thing for
tonight was out before you had to put G
mo before you had to battle royale mode
the game itself I bought it and I
thought it was a pretty okay game but
man when they came out with that battle
royal mode that cranked it up a whole
another notch and yeah the completely
different game pretty much I mean but
let's I mean let's take the body right
so both of these games run basically on
the same the same engine the Unreal
Engine but they're made by two different
teams one took a cartooning type art
style another one took a bland
type art style which realize right this
pub G is based on a mode from I think it
was ARMA 3 or something like that or
another another game so it's not even a
game it was just a mode it's a my that's
what it is
mm-hmm so it's not like they build it
from scratch
mm-hmm but I do think that I mean Club
she obviously was the first one out the
gate so they got the install base
fortnight is right behind it but they
got the install base because it's free
right there's more people right now
playing for tonight then the input of G
eventually the hype was gonna die down
but I've been playing pub G on the PC
that's clean is day one I'm looking at
the top three games played on xbox right
now can you guys tell me the three
Monster Hunter pub G the fortnight three
you have two other gears gears
no you have to the three you'll never
believe and tell well first off who do
you think is the most played game on
that before night fortnight who you
think's the second Babji no because pub
G still put these three bogies three
third number to turn around
ever yeah that's the crazy he's the one
behind pub G now here's the craziest
thing the most played game is fortnight
what do you think the most paid game is
pleasing pub G yeah subjects axe so what
do you think's more important people
playing it the people that actually put
money into the project that they're
playing I mean yeah they're gonna eat
off it but the argument the argument
right now is back to what we were seeing
is like for what diverse from G like
this is what it is right now yeah we act
with this lit wisdom cares you got to
give me that final goodie and you just
about to go into the whole PC you plan
on coffee there we go okay
all right so here's the thing once the
map once the additional maps come over
to the to the Xbox then it's gonna start
back up again right some some of the
hype has kind of died down people are
playing it for a while so they're kind
of weighing in a way but you got to keep
giving them consistent content for them
to keep being engaged and that's what
fortnight has kind of been doing become
it's gonna come with whip up G but it's
just taking a little bit longer but you
can't beat free man I mean literally you
just can't beat free there's literally
nothing you can do to be free oh yeah
try to you know do their marketing as
much as they want the fact that epic
could say this case freeze the best
marketing you could ever going so hard
at each other before diverse thing I'll
tell you this though it's you gotta
realize right it's I think by default
it's gonna go to fortnight because
before tonight don't have any of the
issues that put G hat pub G max on the X
runs like barely at a playable frame
especially if you're coming from the PC
why you playing 60 plus on it it's it's
it's always really unplayable but
they've kind of patched it and it's
workable now so you can still enjoy but
again you can enjoy any game if you're
playing with your friends no matter
higher runs yeah but I think ma'am I am
I gonna tip my head over the fortnight
because they were able to make the game
run beautiful I mean it's beautiful you
have X did you see the mold oh did you
see it yes even I'm not a fortnight god
I gotta admit update that just came out
not only how put G on the eggs play I
purposely kept my behind away from my PC
downstairs cradle says when I hop on it
I put my headset on
and I hear you see it no the invites it
is going yeah nothing beats that yeah
let's get it in soft
I don't yeah king of my royal you are I
know right master back my voice got
progressively worse cuz you heard about
run your voice so I gotta say I gotta
give it to fortnight because I mean hmm
you can't beat free mmm freezer pop pop
jeez is not on PlayStation yet and
that's big that it's not on PlayStation
yet um and then you gotta give it to I
mean epic they have the engine the
engine and and I think about the engine
is that chances are you could never even
dream about getting pop GE to run on a
switch there's rumors about four night
on the switch like this is something
like it would be I don't I'm not saying
that it would increase the player base
that much but the fact that you have the
game that can run on possibly all the
major platforms at the moment is
important and if and again it being free
on the switch we it's doubly important
so I just think like they just have too
many advantages like they own the engine
they know how to maximize that engine
you know yeah is it Chinese choice you
know what I'm think the thing that makes
us different than most like you got
games it's like are the free
counterparts to the you know the Rito
popular mainstream game is their legitly
the same gay just once more casual than
the other
mm-hm he said pub G runs on a phone in
China it could run on this old it the
fortnight gang in the question about
that that mobile pub Zhi Hao closes its
actual Babji like it looks really good
if you have you gotta understand these
phones that we have is 800 900 dollars
Koran if you sit down you may gain for
private or towards are those
phones that actually have really good
graphics cards if you actually make game
for that it's gonna look good it looks
really good I just want to say one thing
to the fortnight flag-bearers I can jump
on a rocket and snipe you in the mouth
and down the block it's not about that
game that's you I would say one thing
like the last 25 the last 25 alive and
pub Jean the last 25 alive
on on fortnight is two entirely
different species like when you get to
like like the last 25 it's like where's
the fortress that's where the rest make
the two games significantly different
see me jumping look quick obviously I'm
biased one club G but I have to admit
what's ah the same is true free is free
at the end of the day free is undefeated
so it to me it's just amazing that pub
she's still able to keep up and let's be
real we know the history right with epic
and pretty much stole their game they
pretty much be someone else and like
we're gonna take your whole house but
put the front porch to the left of the
house and not the right so it's
different it is what it is and I don't
want to disrespect in the sense then
look before tonight the engine is
tremendous you know saying I think the
ultimate differences is what style game
you like right if you like that grit
that military feel though a little bit
more realistic vehicles you're gonna go
with pub G if you like just more of a
fun graphically running smoothly but I
will say this much I don't left thing
like that cartoony you know whole thing
on that I will say like this is what
shout to centers in a chat you know he
lost in is fortnight all day but on what
I say when I draw your line
is I love what Knights
in-game they always got like suits and
all these different things and cool
stuff you can get and it's like when I
play from gym like all I got is this
dirty mop that shirt you know their shoe
I'm like is something else with the
obviously it has to be cosmetic because
you don't want like King said you don't
want to change up game back from what
they need to adopt and steal back what
fortnight's doing right now cuz I think
that's cool like that so somebody would
like crazy somebody in a astronaut suit
but it is par for the course when you
ride a rocket you should be wearing an
astronaut suit so ultimately I'm gonna
rock I'm still gonna rock with a buggy
but I cannot deny that's what I got a
choice as far as well we know what Kings
going with and I like they have
different like if I don't have like a
whole squad of four like fortnight's
more comfortable playing but if I you
have a whole me they're both good play
with with people but one of the biggest
issues I have a fortnight as you can't
prone like that really annoys me I'm
gonna keep it real for now guys this
which I gotta help me I just hate when I
watch the [ __ ] yes for party is God
or important the thing I don't like is I
see like the last five getting into a
shootout and building houses on the fly
shots like Elsa it took me out of it
y'all I would be rub like wait we didn't
do this that way I could build the
Empire State Building at a bit of a
battle that's pathetic
I wish I was getting played and I could
build a house and pub she is drinking
pub G's beat bill yeah I got a strap
receipts for that painful for tonight
though a lot of free wheeling and
dealing with your mouth put your money
where your mouth in the receipts and I
like house input at the top fortnight is
the most painting on Xbox out hacking
you have is the most painting on xbox
like that literally makes no like not
even a little bit of rockets again I
always continue go Raptors we got our
new ILP poll this week and with the
one-year anniversary of the switch now
upon us what do you feel is the most
important in for its continued success
in year two choices are a proper online
voice chat messaging and achievements P
Virtual Console for classic Nintendo
titles huge IPS like smash bros Pokemon
Metroid or D I don't care
Nintendo level FTW Oh give me the
enjoyment next week because I'll be off
work
give me that enjoying that I need that
my life will be up tomorrow Lord Kratos
they thought it was gonna be violence
[Laughter]
have you at the roundtable Wiccan the
frame will find you sir
you guys can find on twitter at jade of
city 16 I'm always keeping you guys
laughing with the mins and the with the
gifts on the ends so thank crying thanks
for
absolute pleasure you know you are
welcome back in the realm of the Lord's
anytime absolute pleasure and this we
finally dispel the rumors that they are
not one person entities just wrapping
this side all in fun
all exact comedy you love what you doing
up there you two are
absolutely light it's like literally
listening to the other person it's funny
ah you can find me next week on IOP I
don't know Twitter I ILP you can find me
on YouTube gaming addict any challenging
games coming up the challenging game
[ __ ] extreme
coopered Tomb Raider it's already like
don't get me wrong like it's a cool game
and all but at the end of the day I'm
just like like okay well I don't like
the point A to point B games like this
is a little open-world a little bit but
at the end of the day like you know
people in my chat all day the entire
time I do it when you go to play
Uncharted like no it's not happening
forward to disturb you love your blood
ball one did very well I saw a lot of
community support
Boyet so that's good to see the
challenging game conquer your sovereign
with the squeaky bad voice but still
survived all the rambling of the Lord's
we can find people find you coming
through me appreciate it
I love always said appreciate the old
game is coming through oh jeez oh jeez
um and I'm you can find me on a PSN xbox
live at bxr and it's Lord sighs I hope
Eagan
I apologize for sounded like somebody
strangled me now we appreciate you
sticking out we know you not feel it
well bro we definitely appreciate
Lord King exquisite extinguisher
it was it was fierce out here we had the
we
to fight off the on salt Florida was a
fair battle it was a lot of respect on
both sides so we can find people fight
first and foremost I would like to say
thank you cradles for coming through and
the the respect that I have for you
hearing the game in history stand up
dude and get perspective on your gaming
system of choice is fair and honest you
know it's not biased so I can respect
that all the way to and I had such a
great time today because if you can look
at the the time frame we have been going
on for three hours
mom and it was action pack and we kept
the people and tools and interacting all
the way do I want to give a shout out to
the chat you rolled with us from
beginning to end I would like to say
shout out to Delilah HD when when I'm
riffing off the top and I'm making jokes
I do apologize if someone who come off
as crash and chauvinistic um that's king
after dog when we playing pub G joke
slipped into here today because when you
target Superman's cape you got to be
afraid of what he's gonna do anything
instigating all the Holloman stop
calling him anchorman all he does is
report stuff keep that in perspective so
if anybody was caught in the wake of
Superman turning around and the gust of
wind was knocking people down I do
apologize but you can find me on xbox a
King David OTW
add me we play we really get it in on
PlayStation Xbox 360 lover oh one that's
a real tag that's me I will pop up it'll
be a little monkey
oh gee because I love monkeys Oh more
switch you never get my social security
numbers am I giving it up if you want
some of the funniest content you can
catch me on Twitter ripping a new one
and somebody who accidentally pokes the
bear no for article spread told you what
you wanted to hear but what you needed
here thanks again Lawrence for coming
through dealing with us to three hours
of foolishness we were extra long day
but I appreciate you sticking it out but
um yeah man I want you to shout out to
the chat everybody that was in the area
late today mom also thanks for the
support on the ILP channel for flash
point number six twenty boxes went off I
want to shout out to Louis specifically
that always shows a lot what chief Tommy
Crisco burly it really means a lot
definitely a lot of love for doing it a
little passion project at this point cuz
we all know Destiny's dead but we trying
to keep the flag no I'm not ending I got
I got some announcements too and I'll
let you rock but don't know you could
you rock first and I got an announcement
so also I wanna say um like I said
thanks out out to everybody you did
support stuff like that make sure you
guys what the inner circle Network the
multiverse briefing with us they relied
too much please go support them brothers
your love will get this whole thing
straight now ain't nobody ducking no
fades over here they gotta chill but I
also want to say also a big announcement
you know the Lord's officially going to
PAX East as media no he doesn't say
everyone at the inner circle network
Lord Cal
Lord anchorman Louis Sam Tauber all the
fans that will actually support in our
articles in this podcast it really means
a lot
there's our first time as media we're
gonna be going out in Boston please hang
out and support the Lord's if you are in
boy
in packs each 2018 we're gonna have some
things cooking up for you there it's
gonna be or something nice absolutely
different it's a little or datacom let
you wrap this thing up all right no I
put a code for pub G in the Rockets is
bad for your help for that much
appreciated on the code stuff like that
cradles and everybody everybody have a
good Sunday and the realm is gonna be
that we got a very special guest next
week aunt don't want to spoil it just
yet don't want to jinx it make sure you
guys stay to it and on that low enjoy
your Sunday we out
[Music]